this is Jocko podcast number 114 with
Echo Charles and me jakka willing
good evening echo good evening and
tonight we have a guest on the podcast
for the fourth time the fourth
appearance which is no surprise really
because this is a guy that I went to war
with started a business with wrote a
book with actually watched him get
married and have kids and buy houses and
go from a let's say a wild single man
going to live a Friday night like it was
his last night ever to a guy with a
diaper in one hand and a bag of cheddar
bunnies in the other hands trying to
tame his son who at 1 years old was like
a hard-headed borderline psychotic
version of himself and I also saw this
guy in much harsher environments and in
some of the most challenging situations
I saw him bear the incredibly heavy
weight of leading men in combat and also
the crushing weight of losing some of
those men I still see that weight on his
shoulders can I see it in his eyes and I
wish I could take some of it away but I
can't
and as we learn in the SEAL Teams we
don't complain
we shoulder our share of the weight
which shoulder our share of the burden
and we drive on and I've seen him stand
up when I needed him to stand up when
what I was asking for was more than I
could have asked or should have expected
from anyone and I watched him time and
time and time again move out move out
into the darkness toward the unknown
toward the violence toward the enemy
whose mission was to maim or to kill him
and his men but he went and he went
every time and he went without fail and
his name is Rafe Babbitt and if you want
a more thorough background of life you
can listen to the other times that he's
been on this podcast he was on number 11
number 34 number 65 you should listen to
those first before you listen to this
one you can also read the book that we
wrote it's called extreme ownership it's
about our experiences in combat and the
leadership lessons we learned there but
for now here we are once again and Lafe
welcome back to the show thanks for
having him and we had a couple different
options on what we were gonna do this
time around and tweet it out you know if
anybody has any questions and we got a
lot of questions so I know I can answer
questions
we'll just say in it really in a very
in-depth manner from time to time sure
and we got a lot of questions so I you
know we we just took down a bunch of the
questions and I'll read through some of
them we'll try and burn through a bunch
of these questions that we got from
everybody let's get some ready to get
some okay like I said life is always
ready which is Anna
stand by to get some stand by for people
that know don't know what that means and
we often put that out in social media I
don't think people recognize what that
actually means to us that we we knew we
would say this all the time in combat or
in training scenarios when you knew that
I mean it was about to go down bullets
were gonna be flying around explosion
could be going off and you hear someone
very clearly over the radio just in a
real convoys come up and be like
stand by to get some yeah so get a
chuckle out of that I always get a
chuckle out of that one
yeah that's uh that's it's a true
statement though right you know yes some
but when you get stayed in that manner
you know when you should be let go and
be like standby to get some it's pretty
awesome I was on my first deployment and
we were driving driving south from
Baghdad and and we got ambushed
and we were like like a five or six
vehicle convoy and the ambush hit the
tail and I was in I was in the number
two vehicle as normal for you know the
for platoon commander at the time I'm in
the number two vehicle the tail end of
the ambush gets ambushed or tailing the
convoy gets camp ambushed and what I
mean it's very clear it's RPGs that are
going over the convoy and explosions and
machine-gun fire and it's really obvious
we're getting ambushed and but we're on
a highway and we're moving fast so we
you know it's you know I was like a push
through you know I mean like we didn't
stop at all didn't even hesitate and
then we continued down the road and I
asked for the you know like up count
from the rims like up count and so is
you know I hear like vehicle six is
upset vehicle five is up and the vehicle
for is up and and it gets the front and
I'm like Roger we're up keep rolling
and then another maybe another minute
goes by and my platoon chief great guy
he's in the back vehicle rear you know
in the rear vehicle so that's how you
break you know break it up so if
something happens he's in control and
and he comes up in the radio and he's
like he's like hey sir just wanna let
you know we got ambushed you back here
did you know that and I go like this
Roger we got back we had a good laugh
about that one but it was pretty good
times so yeah all right get into some
questions this is a question that
actually came a very similar question
that I had when it when I had Tony on
and most of these questions because I
said these questions are for life coming
on the podcast and Muslim are directed
at you and I'll chime in or whatever if
I feel the need but you like that so
here we go first one
Lafe how often did you disagree with
Jacko's commands and how many times did
you actually let him know also how did
you handle either situation so there you
go
I disagree with Jocko every minute
listen we actually we had a it's a great
question and look Jacque on our
different people we have different views
of the world we have there were there
were times when you know his job was
your job was strategic and you're
looking at the bigger strategic picture
my job was tactical I'm looking at the
tactical picture sometimes you can make
the tactical decision that could impact
the strategic mission and and ever it
was very rare though that we ever had
any kind of disagreement on those things
I think you know there are a number
times that when what I always liked
about Jocko and I think people look at
you and think oh he's this big Touma
dating guide and I remember our
commanding officer actually we were
talking to him and of course he loved
our task in it and he was like yeah you
guys in Bruges he was like he was
talking to me and the Delta platoon
commander and and said you guys you got
to do what Jocko says or he'll choke you
out and we were kind of laughing about
that because we were we were trained you
Jitsu every morning I haven't choked out
but hundreds of times it's not even a
crack
but it was it was never we never did
what you said because it was fear
intimidation or like we have to do what
he says because he's in charge what I
was loved about you and your leadership
was that I knew that I could push back
on stuff and you were gonna listen to me
and it was it was interesting
interesting for me to see that as you
know we built a relationship I could I
could come in and be like hey I think we
ought to do this and and and very rarely
would you you know you would never say
like no do it this way because it's my
way but even very very rarely would you
would you say sometimes you might get
well we want to go in this direction
that here's why I want to do this but
most of the time you would actually just
say hey we'll talk me through that okay
what how's that gonna work and and and
you would give me the opportunity and
others know between the opportunity to
come up with it with a plan and kind of
analyze it and look at it and and give
it give it a shot and so that's that's
where I always loved about about that I
mean a couple disagreements it that came
up you know for me something that we
talk about all the time you know with
our business echelon front when we
talking talking to companies and
leadership teams going through the
workup cycle you know we always talk
about people want to hire folks and just
kind of let them let them run and you
know people won't say hey give them give
them the opportunity to go out and
succeed and and a lot of bosses want to
kind of you know what just hey I'm
really busy hire someone with experience
put them and put them in in position you
kept really really tight reins on us and
initially that was super frustrating to
me I mean I I remember being in our
mount training military operations urban
terrain training for folks that don't
know what that means where we're in the
Mach cinderblock city and we've talked
about that on the podcast and talked
about that often here for other folks at
other podcasts but that was it I wanted
to plan these things I'm the platoon
commander I want to be in charge I
remember you saying hey we should do
this or let's plan it this way and I
remember wanting to kind of push back
against that and and oftentimes but I
recognize like as we're going on you're
actually training me and giving me the
giving me opportunities operations that
I hadn't done any of those operations
previously so you were teaching me and
mentoring me and once we got to the
battlefield you just Unleashed us to get
and a couple of times I do remember some
pushback where you came up and gave me
some direction and you know where you
said hey why don't you try this or do
that and one of those times in
particular was when I was you know when
I was trying to get get I remember a
number of times and one of them out in
our desert training facility out at what
we call land warfare and I'm trying to
get the platoon to to pull back to a
position and we're trying to trying to
patrol out and you gave me he told me to
actually you know stop trying to put put
a bunch of detail information out of the
radio like Jews verbal commands do it
this way and I you know immediately my
ego getting the way I was in it was
frustrating because the team wasn't
doing what I want him to do and that's
like step number one of the frustration
so a team isn't doing what I was so
automatically my meters kind of starting
to get pegged in like no drag no one's
listening to me
so when Jaco comes up to give me at some
direction of like hey you ought to do
this my immediate pushback is like no
I'm not gonna do that you know and I
didn't say that but I just I was like I
kind of bristled a little bit I remember
kind of bristling that and I was like
okay let me think about it what do we
you know he hasn't told me wrong before
and I was like let me give that shot
it's like okay I'll do that use verbal
commands get everybody moving do and you
do that over and over and over again
throughout multiple training scenarios
and then on the bow as well were that's
what built up trust the wooden when you
did tell me to do some was like I'm
gonna give it a shot and and it worked
yeah it expand on that a little bit the
verbal command thing is so you get guys
that there's a bunch of people you know
you got your got opportunity just take
this case you got a platoon sixteen guys
there in various terrain features one
guys in a little in a little ravine one
guys up on a little Knoll other guys be
honest rub so there's a little bit of
dispersion with your troops and you want
to get them to do something you want to
get them to fall back or you want to get
in a monster where you are and maybe the
shooting stopped or whatever but you you
want to control all these people at the
same time and so what you think is hey
I'll just get on the radio and I'll tell
everyone hey everyone I'm back about a
hundred meters back there's a little
piece of terrain sticking out there's a
rock by it I'm behind that rock and if
you guys start peeling back here too
Northwest at about zero nine zero
degrees that's where you find me
okay so now what does that come across
like on a transmission for a guy that's
shooting him machine gun he hears like a
cop come back he that's what he hears
nothing or anything and and so and
you've given this long complex direction
and what you really need is hey everyone
fall back here now that's what that's
what they need to hear and so then you
do it and you realize that now we have a
thing in the SEAL Teams where you pass
the command and so when you hear a loud
verbal command everyone passes it now
everyone heard it and now everyone comes
back to your position but this is the
essence of in the book extreme ownership
this is really the essence of simple
like it's simple clear communications
and that's one of those things that we
once you learn it you're like yeah if I
if you have people with my team isn't
doing what I wanted to do not that they
don't want to they don't even know what
do you want to do cuz you're giving it
in such a complex way I said I gave that
council hundreds of times once I was
running the training on the west coast I
gave that council hundreds I'm like hey
man just tell everyone a simple command
right now to get him to do something so
that holds true I don't say and I'll
tell you another situation where you you
kind of disagreed with me and we we were
working with a company I'm not gonna
mention the company's name we were
working with a company and there was a a
sea of like a mid-level but a somewhat
senior leader and you didn't like him
and the reason you didn't like him
because he wasn't really that confident
he had messed some things up and his
whole his division was suffering a
little bit and you were you were kind of
like hey Jocko we should talk about
getting this guy fired well it wasn't
that he was it just wasn't that he was
competent his division was suffering
like they were like hey what's the this
guy is dragging us down this is a major
issue and and and I was we were getting
massive negative feedback there was
impact in the team particular from a guy
who was supposed to be the knowledgeable
guy that was able to groom and mentor
the the junior leaders you know
underneath him and you know I thought
men why should they keep this guy this
is he's actually dragging the team down
and you said
well strategically it if they get root
you know I think you're rid of this guy
it's gonna it's gonna actually have some
impact the strategic mission they're
trying to do it
there's the senior leaders we're gonna
quote you know maybe question what was
going on there after you remove the key
leader from so strategically at that
point in the company that individual who
was you know again we'll just say
incompetent and also unlikes
he had really really good political and
relationship connections with the we'll
say a parent company but the people that
controlled the funding and so we could
get rid of this guy but all of a sudden
all these people that were funding this
company there was going to be problems
and I was like hey if we get rid of that
guy we're gonna cut a lot of
relationship courts so we let's try and
find a way to mitigate as much we can do
and we disagreed upon it but basically
you know you fundamentally got the other
leader in that division to figure out
how to work with the guy and got him
trained up and and then that guy took
enough control that they mitigated the
non performer kind of out of the picture
and it worked out well and I think the
lesson there is that you know like I
mentioned earlier you can win the
tactical battle and lose the strategic
war and you certainly don't want to do
that I think you got to recognize it
when you're whether it's terminating
someone or making decisions I think
that's where we had you know you had
that strategic picture in mind and and I
was focus a little more on the tactical
side so you got a you got to keep you
can make the right tactical call and can
have some real strategic consequences in
the cascade and caused you a lot more
problems I think though that the my true
answered this question on our most
fundamental disagreement came on patches
and that was Jocko was understood as
seals that we needed to be squared away
we wanted to be stormtroopers into you
bruiser that's what we wanted up we want
to all look the same
we wanted to have you know squirt away
haircuts quarter our uniforms everybody
in the same same gear that's hard for
seals cuz seals often want to just kind
of wear a you know mix-and-match of
uniforms and and kind of whatever gear
they want to look cool
straight up long hair beer to all those
things you recognized we needed to when
you do that and and guys can get out of
control we have all these patches made
that are you know that are like look at
these cool guy got patches all over me
and and and and that seals are some of
the best you know the biggest offenders
of that so jock I was like no patch yeah
and just to expand on this a little bit
more but that strategically from the
army from the Marine Corps the army in
the Marine Corps when they look at
someone that's not in the square to you
squared away uniform they think them
they think to themselves hey if this guy
can't even wear a squared-away uniform
how can he operate out in the
battlefield and then that's what what
they think and good for them because
it's a true statement if you've got
someone that can't mind some some
details and look squared away
then how can how can I expect them to do
their job well now in this in the SEAL
Teams and really in all soft communities
there's some absolute laxity when it
comes to uniform requirements that's why
you see pictures of guys doing this you
know dressing out of uniform and mixing
matching uniforms it's it's the way it
is and you know what my in my in my
deepest knowledge I know that you can
have it and this is a classic military
quote is you know an inspection ready
platoon has never passed combat and a
combat ready platoon has never passed
inspection it's it's a commonly known
thing that I understand and I get and
but especially we're new in the battle
space we're just showing up here we got
you know Marines and and army soldiers
and senior leadership that we're gonna
be working for and I say okay we're
gonna make a good this is the base that
fundamentally we're gonna make a good
first impression we're gonna look
squared away which means we're gonna you
know have squared-away haircuts we're
gonna buy our boots and we're gonna wear
a normal looking uniform which means we
don't have crazy-looking patches that
that make us look different right
because it's that's the thing that
you're saying the thing you're saying is
look at me that's what you're saying
look at me I'm cool that's what a patch
is it's hey look at me I'm special and
then and obviously I don't like that
attitude and so here we go back to the
patches so we I mean when you told me we
were on board with everything on the
same page and we saw eye-to-eye on so
many things it certainly me and the
double toe commander would you
absolutely and but that wasn't know why
but for one reason I
we got together a sec we designed our
own patches were like where would you
say we you mean you and the Delta me and
the Delta platoon commander we me in the
Delta commander said we're gonna design
some batches for tasking a bruiser and I
don't know I don't know what why if we
just had an idea that this was gonna be
a historic unit this is gonna be
something we wanted to be a part of but
we felt like we needed tasks in two
packs and I felt like you secretly
wanted us to have them even though you
told us not to do it so sounds like we
designed these batches one of them I
used the Lord humungus from the road
warrior for one and the other one we had
oh we had a big cow skull and and it was
so we had these 2d patches we went out
we had a made was a we I secretly had
him chef I secretly had them distributed
to the both laterns and we keep them in
our shoulder patch pocket and we B so
we'd be in a convoy ready to roll out
Joc would come out see everybody off
shake hands with everybody and we'd be
launched on the operation and they we'd
come up over the radio my leading
patient come up with already black
patches on everyone pull the badges out
slap the badges on and then we although
we got busted when there was an embedded
reporter with there was an embedded
reporter with one of the unit's we were
working with and there were some photos
of patches so we got busted although you
didn't you didn't come down on me hard
like that you just well they just
because you mentioned that we had this
conversation on text the other day I'm
actually I just pulled out my phone to
read this text back and forth we were
just talking about you were basically
saying hey you know you let's not forget
he didn't want us to wear patches and
and and then and then I wrote back to
you a don't forget that while I was out
outwardly disapproving inside I was
smiling knowing that a little rebellious
Ness is an important is important for
leaders to possess and that esprit de
corps Trump's compliance and uniformity
oh that's an actual text conversation we
were avid that's kind of jacked up isn't
it but my point is like you you know
obviously it meant something to you and
it was bringing the team together it's
like when you go through boot camp and
the jo-jo instructors will let you get
away with something cuz they know it's
beautifying the team and that's what it
was for me it's like okay and also how
much leadership capital my gonna expend
cuz even though I just made it sound
like was a big deal at them that and and
also we had earned a good reputation we
do it wasn't the first impression
anymore it was like the impression had
been made and the impression was solid
and so now it's like oh yeah these guys
are these guys oh yeah they're actually
a unit identifying patch mm-hmm so we
actually and we gave that patch to the
brigade commander you know it departed
which was awesome and and I'm very proud
to say that there's not a whole lot up
on the wall in the Jocko gym but in the
garage there but there is a tu bruiser
patch Lord humungus represents there's a
seven echo from my from my echo platoon
at team seven and there's a seal team
one patch I mean a sticker that's my
that's my wall of glory stapled to the
wall awesome all right next question
so that's the one question we're 20
minutes deep you gotta like that all
right next question can you discuss the
evolution of echelon front was the
company ready for the explosive
popularity of extreme ownership what
kinds of challenges have you faced we
face all kinds of challenges and the
same challenges that that any business
faces certainly and you know for for us
it's been learned to the firehose it's
been it's been an awesome experience so
but I think just like any just like our
our combat experience we would app
through the battlefield we learned we
educated ourselves about things that we
didn't know about and and and we've
grown I mean I don't think anyone could
I don't know if we could have predicted
just how you know widely disseminated
the book would be or you know the
popular things that we're talking about
we knew they were powerful it's the
whole reason we wrote the books there's
a massive demand signal for it and and I
think you know as we work with companies
now to through our come to on front I
mean there's just we're able to go and
and deliver some impact to these teams
in a way that other people aren't able
to do it because most of the the folks
in that space are it's a feel good thing
you're out there to talk about a you
guys you're great and let's harness your
inner potential and all this kind of
stuff and I laugh when people call us
motivational speakers because I say look
motivational speakers tell you how good
good you are and we're here to tell you
how much you suck
you gotta get better if you want to win
so that's what we do and I think it's
the same same way that brutally honest
assessment of yourself your team the
same thing that makes you know seal unit
success on the battlefield and other
military units is the same thing that
we're doing now with our company
certainly you know all the challenges of
bookkeeping and and and you know the
building processes and and paying taxes
and I mean just that you know regulatory
environment those things that make it
hard for any business launching but just
like on the battlefield where we can
either [__] about the paperwork or we
can figure out a way to most efficiently
get it done so that we could actually go
accomplish the mission which you
instilled in us like hey I can complain
about it all day I gotta figure out a
way to get this done and make it happen
because that's what it requires to do
and that's what we've done with our
business and it's it's been awesome
and frankly what I love is working with
leaders and so many of the folks that
contact doesn't want to work with us
they they're already doing well and they
want to do even better and it's just so
much fun to work with folks who want to
just constantly grow and learn and we
grow and learn all the time from them
you know yeah I think you hit it all
next question in battle having the high
ground is crucial how do you see this
principle applied to the business world
and and we have I've answered this
question before with the statement take
the high ground or the high ground will
take you so business world
okay well tactically what do you think
why are you the high ground well I think
that's that's the real question right
the why is the high ground important and
obviously you know out of thousands of
years of military history that the high
ground is always important
by the way I did have I did have a
training instructor a few years ago my
SEAL team days who we had he said look
at your high-speed altimeter watch and
and you get get down behind something so
he was basically telling us like if that
thing's going up you're wrong
things should be going down used he was
telling us to take the low ground which
was which was kind of laughable so out
out doing thousands of years of military
history always take the low ground no
don't do that you want to take the high
ground the reason is because tactically
if you're on the high ground
you you have got a better shooting
position you can shoot down on people
who can't hide very well because you
you're above them which is why it was
awesome for us to be in in buildings and
if we could get a three or four storey
building and this you know in the city
of Ramadi the urban environment it was
awesome but it's no different in the
business environment and and what you
have to do is just identify the key
terrain what is the key to the high
ground is key terrain so that that
doesn't it doesn't necessarily mean that
you know you're gonna go to climb to the
mountaintop because that's where you
want to be but but if that Ridgeline
that's on the high ground gives you you
know tackle Vantage on the battlefield
that's it's the same thing in the
business world if you're if you're a
retailer you know where's that key
terrain where's the intersection that
that's that you want to be that's gonna
give your business the best you know the
best chance to succeed if you're you
know any space I mean there's there's
key terrain that you can identify where
you want to be a part of it if it's if
you're a private equity company you're
trying to get break into some new you
know some new technology or new new new
particular industry and that that's
that's key terrain you need to be
focused on that and identifying that as
critical why it's important and and
everyone's gonna be you're gonna be
behind for that and you want to be
aggressive you want have a maneuver
because if you get there first you're
gonna be a lot better position it's it's
flank or beef flank we always say you
know you're maneuver on the enemy of
they're gonna maneuver on you so what
you don't want to do is wait for
somebody else to get in a better
position and then you actually have to
fight your way out of that it's it's not
good like in jujitsu you don't want to
wait to someone's gonna mount you that's
not a good place to be or take your back
right you want to try to prevent that
before you can get there and and if you
can do that to them first and you're in
a much better position and I think it's
no different in the business world I had
was working with a company the other day
and basically what they were saying was
that their competitor was lying about
them to to as they're trying to close
accounts they're their competitor would
go in the field and say oh yeah this
this the company are this to this
company they don't do it right and they
don't have these accounts and they're
they're going out of business and
everything's bad so there's there's
their competitors were out there lying
about them and you know the sales leader
said you know I don't I don't want to
stoop to their level you know and start
throwing lies out there about them or
making accusations I think that's you
know I said well no you don't want to
take the load
you want to take the high ground and he
said well yeah but at the same time what
what are we supposed to do and I said
well you actually have the most powerful
weapon in this fight the weapon that you
have is the truth
you have the you have the truth but
you're not getting the truth out there I
said what do you do when you do close an
account what do you do how do you
publicize it needs to cool we really
don't and I said well do you do you do a
press release when you close a big count
no we don't do that do you advertise it
anyway no we don't do that and I said so
the most powerful weapon you have is the
truth and you're not utilizing that
weapon you need to have a propaganda arm
at this company that's gonna go out
there and explain that all the wins and
what the truth really is and that will
be more powerful and then you can
maintain the high ground and by the way
when those other companies are out there
lying about you and then people find out
it makes them look even worse so they've
broken their trust with with the
potential client so yeah always take the
high ground always take that ground it
might not win you the short-term battle
in business right you know you see you
see companies you know like a I can sell
you this thing right now I can I can
paint repaint this thing put a fresh
coat of paint on it and sell it to you
that's not the high ground right that's
the low ground because it's gonna it's
gonna fail you because what's underneath
the hood is crap so that might win me
you know that one sale but what's gonna
happen in the long road taking the low
ground you're gonna you're gonna put on
Yelp that you've got a crappy deal and I
did you know I repainted something and
sold it to you and it wasn't worth it
and now that reputation is gonna spread
in the end it's not gonna help you if
you take the high ground hey here's
what's going on with this vehicle or
whatever you're selling take the high
ground there's no clear thing about that
is is we see so many leaders and some of
those successful people we do that
recognize how important that is to build
relationships and they're they're
willing to lose a sale or lose a you
know to send someone to a competitor
just just to make sure that person gets
exactly what they need and they're
building a relationship so that means
more business gets sent to them as it
resists what you started talking about
it's a strategic win as opposed to a
tactical end and that's what you've got
to be focused on and that's really as a
leader that's what you got to be looking
at you got to be looking at your
frontline people and making sure that
they've they're not just out there
trying to win every little tactical
battle but they're going backwards
strategically so keep that in mind
that's why you have to detach that's why
you have to stay out of the weeds and
when you get in the weeds you got to
step back out of them because otherwise
you lose track of that and you're gonna
end up in the low ground before you even
recognize it
all right next question how do you
control rumors and gossip within an
organization that's pretty easy you just
you just talked about being you know
getting out there with the truth and
your propaganda armed outside your come
it's no different inside your company
you've got to make sure that people eat
it's an interesting that when you work
we work with leaders sometimes you see
people that write why I don't want to
share this with my people you know cuz I
don't know what they might think like
there are they're thinking yeah
something that may be totally not true
they're not just sitting there not
thinking anything because you're not
sharing it with them they're coming up
to their own conclusions which may be
completely false or opposite but like we
say in the in the Navy all the time you
know perception is reality that becomes
reality
so you've got a you got a you can defeat
the gossip and rumors by actually just
sharing the truth be open with people
and and and and and be in first out
there with a message so people get an
understanding and even when horrible bad
things go wrong extreme ownership right
if if you take ownership for that and
say hey listen this happened here's what
we're doing to fix it here's what we're
doing to turn things around it's kind of
the people people are not gonna lose
respect for you in the organization
they're actually gonna gain respect for
you as a result something we talk about
all the time so don't be afraid to do
that again just get the message out
there and and be transparent and talk to
folks if you don't tell people what's
going on they're gonna make up their own
ideas of what's going on and the thing
that I have to I have to we we have to
we have to take this just a little bit
further right just a little bit further
because we talked about transparency
right and that word gets thrown around
all the time and of the idea that you're
just gonna you that the idea that you're
just gonna tell everyone exactly what's
going on and that sounds great and it's
like hey I'm a fully transparent leader
and I'm gonna tell you what's going on
but there's times where you actually
don't want to do that there's times
where
you have to maneuver and you have to be
tactful and some of the things that you
might tell someone actually is not the
right thing to do now and I I'm not
saying we're gonna be dishonest with our
people I'm not saying that and I'm
saying that transparency is a great
thing but I mean just on a personal
level if Leif's leaves up working for me
and he's not doing he's doing something
horrible is the best way to go about
that to fully true full transparency is
hey life you're doing horrible at this
is that the best way to do it in front
of the entire in front of you right is
that is that it's full transparency
right hey I'm fully transparent okay
everyone welcome to the meeting today by
the way I just wanted to point out that
life to mrs. numbers again and he's a
loser
that might be what I'm thinking that's
fully transparent hey guys just beat and
and you love lists you write just being
transparent Leif's and Leif's a loser he
missed his numbers again and you know
what I'm actually thinking about firing
him just in case anyone was wondering so
that's that's my getaway to close the
business Friday did I do a good job
right so so let's not get carried away
right you know what is the smart way
this smart ways to maneuver the smart
way is to say okay lace not doing what
he what he no wants to what he should be
doing if I go and accuse him of failing
what's his reaction gonna be how is it
what so what I do instead instead I go I
want to take ownership of it and so
instead I say hey life you know eight he
comes and come to come come on laughs I
want to talk to about a couple things so
he comes to my office or not in a public
place and now it's hey Lafe hey man I
noticed that you you know you missed
your numbers and I'm thinking that maybe
I'm not giving you the kind of support
that you need to get where you need to
be is there anything else that you need
from me so that you can win again inside
sure I'm thinking life you pathetic
loser
you missed your numbers again right but
I'm not gonna do that so the full
transparency thing I get it and it makes
sense but we do have to consider the
tertiary and the secondary and tertiary
effects of the things that we say
especially as a leader you what you say
has a lot of impact as a leader and
sometimes I see leaders they make a
little off-the-cuff remark about
something you know oh that won't matter
oh okay so
doesn't matter or so so this little
thing you know hey hey boss we wanted to
get this this task done by this date is
it still important odd doesn't matter
okay so it doesn't matter so what I was
working on for last month and a half
doesn't matter okay cool great I was
fully transparent so just be careful use
tact use your brain
yeah that's that's 100 percent correct I
I think you know what I was trying to
explain in the first situation is I mean
I was having a conversation with a
leader that we work with who was you
know telling me that there was a key
leader in his team that didn't want to
share with any of his key leaders that
they you know they they're the he didn't
want to share with the key leaders that
they were they were having having some
issues and having some dire straits
wondering you know getting to a point
where they're wondering hey I don't know
if we're gonna make payroll you know a
few months from now if we don't turn
these things around but I don't want to
share that with them because I don't
want him to panic mmm and when I when I
heard that I was like what kind of panic
are they gonna have when they find out
yeah they can't make payroll but no one
told him of that and they thought
everything was great so the pen is gonna
be a hundred times worse yeah then and
and that's that's the kind of
transparency I'm talking about we're
like listen you need to go and have a
direct conversation to say guys here's
where we're at yeah and that should be
something to help get them in gear be
like listen we have got to we've got to
hit these numbers we've got to get
things going again we got to turn
performance around or this is where
we're gonna be next quarter if we don't
do that and I think those that's the
kind of thing I'm talking about where
you're not keeping the secrets is it not
helping you out because by the way
everyone knows the numbers right so they
know they already probably know you're
in dire straits and they're thinking
well I better find a backup job and
they're gonna leave and now you're an
even worse straight so yeah absolutely
you don't need to hide information from
from the team alright you know what we
actually have like a few questions on
the muster that people asked one of them
was one of them was why should I come to
the muster what do you think why should
you come to the muster by the way the
muster in case you don't know the muster
is a leadership event is it seminar
gathering I don't have the ring oh okay
I like to gather with that leaders so
the muster is a leadership gathering
where we get together and we talk about
leadership and we have them twice each
well this one what happened twice here
but anyways why should someone come to
the muster what do you think what I love
about the muster is well you have to
understand that we talked to hundreds of
the we've actually worked with we talked
to thousands of leaders over the last
six years that we've had this company
echelon front working with hundreds of
companies and at about every industry
you can imagine and we speak a lot of
leadership conferences we speak at them
all the time and there is nothing like
the muster there just isn't anything out
there like the muster nothing even comes
close and the reason I love it I mean I
just get super excited to be there and
be a part of that stuff and I even use
words like magical to describe it on
previous podcasts which I took some
heavies for took a lot of heavies for
out there it was pretty much there were
there was a pretty good like Disney
Disney memes Disney memes go in there
that was pretty good but the reason the
muster is so amazing is it's just
different from anything else that we do
and I think when I think about what
really makes the muster different it's
the people that are there it's the
content that we're talking about it's
the impact that it has and you know so
who comes from us or the the reason
that's so awesome is that there are
leaders from all over the place and
these leaders are hell-bent on
dominating their universe I mean these
are people that are there they're in the
game and they're from every type of
business every type of industry I mean
we have entrepreneurs we have senior
executives from from major companies we
have mid-level managers we have
frontline leaders and we have people who
really aren't even in a leadership
position maybe with no direct reports
but are aspiring to be that way and grow
and learn we get we get police and
firefighters and other law enforcement
officers members of the military and
they're serving out there on our front
lines or the home front and abroad and
these are the most committed people I've
ever met you know it's it's it's one way
to quantify this or when we're at the
monster
the like the hotel staff will will come
up and they'll be like oh my god this is
crazy
cuz for instance the doors to open to
actually get in the morning of the
muster they open at eight o'clock right
or if turn I guess 7:00 7:15 or 7:45
because it starts at 8:00
7:45 the doors open up and most I mean
we like you said we go to these
conference all the time everyone's
listening been to some kind of
conference and it's you know people are
meandering around and they're coming in
late they don't really care at the
muster it's like the doors open at 7:45
everyone's out in the hallway and we're
out in the hallway hanging out with
everyone at you know 7 o'clock and
that's after we do a 4:45 PT in the
morning we do because we do a little get
some and that's another thing like the
hotel people will clearing it with the
hotel we're just letting them know like
hey there's gonna be a large gathering
of people in in front of the hotel in
the morning and they're like well what
time and we're like Oh 4:45 and then
they say well like how many people we're
like well there's 450 people here so
there's gonna be about 450 people here
and sure enough there it is and that's
what the whole muster is like oh we say
hey we're gonna restart in 10 minutes
and everyone goes out and then come back
in 10 minutes everyone seated ready to
rock and roll so that's that's the and
that's it's funny to hear that from an
outside perspective cuz we're in it but
the hotel people always make comments
about they say we even we never you know
Kyle say hey I've been I've been running
conferences here for 22 years I've never
seen a group of people like this so that
to me shows you what kind of people show
up at the muster when the end when the
doors open it's just bum-rush in there
everyone wants to be in that front row
engage they can ask and not just so they
can you know so they can actually ask
questions so they can actually engage
with us and that's what I love about
those folks I mean they just they're not
there to feel good about themselves
right they're there to take a hard look
in the mirror and and learn and grow and
get better and and and so they can
better and be more effective leaders so
they can lead and win in their teams
whatever they happen to be doing now so
you just kind of talked about then the
other question was who comes the mustard
it's really every different type of
leader the another question that we got
about the muster is what do we talk
about the mustard
for what that's the other piece that I
really like about is its content right
it's its content that that we talk about
it of course I love telling war stories
as you all know from this podcasts we
like talking about war stories we'd like
to talk about our time and the teams and
even when you put that photo up there of
you know of us and Ramadi from back in
the day and you know just it just brings
back great memories I mean those will
always be some of the absolute best
times of my life certainly some of the
worst times of my life as well but but
mostly some of the absolute best times
of my life and and so we get to talk
about that but not just in a way that's
that's that's a cool story but it has
impact and I think taking the taking the
combat leadership lessons we talked
about from extreme ownership and
applying them directly to you know to
people's lives and and what they do and
how to overcome their challenges that's
what it's about it's it's super engaging
and for us you know for me and job this
isn't a standard Leadership Conference
where there's like 40 different speakers
and the the main folks kind of get up
there and spend a few hours I'm we're
we're there the whole time and we're
there to engage with leaders it's me
it's Jocko it's Dave Burke it's JP
Jenelle from our echelon front team
we're there we're the guys on stage and
even during the breaks we're talking the
leaders that are coming up and asking
questions we're engaging with them no
green room in Q&A nobody there is in the
green room there is it someplace we're
hiding behind the curtain there isn't
somewhere in the back where life is
getting cucumbers put on his eyes take a
load off sir
sipping sipping my jock of white TV look
and that's you know these these folks
are there to get their questions
answered and ask hard questions the
thing that you really really get
granular on a lot and that's that's what
it is you're taking like you understand
the principles it's like it's like
learning a jujitsu move from one person
and they teach you a fundamental basic
move and you're like okay I understand
that and then compared to okay now
you're getting getting a private lesson
like that's like in a class right you a
this is the arm lock then you get a
private lesson with someone
that goes in and adapts the technique to
your body style to the opponents that
you're facing the adjustments that you
need to make that's the kind of
granularity we get because the move the
the more you see these different angles
and the other great thing is because
with all these different people that you
got there and we do group exercises
where now you're sitting down and we
purposely don't want people to sit with
with industries that they already work
with so in one group you'll get a CEO
you'll get a firefighter you'll get a
startup business owner you'll get a
mid-level manager and you'll get it some
you know regular corporate EVP and
they'll all be sitting at the same table
and we'll give them a problem we'll give
them a task and they'll come up with a
solution and they'll relate it to how it
affects their lives and their business
and when you see stuff from different
angles like that and you're all applying
we're all speaking the same language
because everyone there's obviously read
the book everyone understands that
everyone understands fundamentally what
the principles are but now we're getting
to see how they impact people's
businesses and lives and leadership
roles from all these different
perspectives and it just makes you that
much better that's why during these
exercises like I'll say go come to float
around to these different tables and
listen but the first day but I'll get to
I'll be like oh man these guys are your
I'm sitting there learning cuz you got
like I said you got a firefighter that's
explaining to a CEO what you do in a
situation where your team has decided
that they're not gonna follow this
procedure anymore and they have good
reason why they don't want to like it's
one thing when you're when your team
doesn't follow the procedure and you say
hey you gotta follow this procedure and
you and they say well why and you say
you explained it to them and they go
okay that makes sense but what about
when you tell them to follow the
procedure and they have a reason that
actually makes sense then what are you
gonna do well that's what you learn at
the muster that's where you make the
progress so that's good one last
question that we got about the the
muster is what kind of impact do you see
from people that have been to the muster
the impact is is is obvious in that the
number of people who are there that are
talking about how they just got promoted
you know are they they just got put in
this in this position of greater
responsibility and
and authority on their teams are they've
been recognized for their exceptional
performers or the folks who've Cove
who've come back from that and we hear
about on a social media or reach out to
us via email or come back to a monster
talk about that from what they you know
what would it happen to them previously
the number of leaders who come and see
what we're doing and bringing their
teams you know that's what's pretty
awesome I mean that to me when a when it
when a CEO from a company comes checks
out what we're doing and brings 25 of
his to his team members back to be a
part of that because he recognizes the
impact that can have I'd say his team
and will have and it's it just it's
awesome to see that I mean these are the
most again the most committed people you
could ever be around and they just they
leave there with the knowledge to
directly apply things and solve problems
and they learn from us they learn from
each other just as you said and part of
that too I think is a recognition that
these kinds of problems that I'm having
are not unique to me they're not unique
to the market that I'm in they're not
unique to my industry but their
leadership problems and they and they
apply everywhere and I'm trying to get a
diverse group of people to focus their
efforts to and need to support one
another accomplish a mission just like
everybody else and in every other
industry in in the business world as a
first responder the military doesn't
matter it's the same thing and these
same techniques apply everywhere and
it's just that's why it's awesome I love
the muster and and I can't wait I can't
wait to meet those folks and and that's
why so many people come back again and
again and again and it's just it's just
an awesome event it's the best thing
that they were a part of and and frankly
if you don't want to have that good look
in the mirror that hard look in the
mirror to yourself and half answer some
tough questions about where you can do
better
you probably shouldn't come because it's
not for you it's it's for people who are
eager to destroy their competition and
dominate the universe and that starts
with looking at themselves and taking
ownership and solving problems so they
can win yeah it's it's interesting cuz
if you think about it I was talking
about this yesterday like every problem
that you have in an organization is
gonna be solved by leadership that's it
that's it that's what its gonna get
solved by every problem that is in an
organization is going to be solved by
leadership I don't care if it's because
you miss numbers
if you got bad process I don't care if
you got the wrong people in the wrong
positions it all those problems are all
about leadership because if you got a
bad process there's a leader that's
allowing that process to be in place if
you've got bad people then there's a
leader that's not either training those
people are getting rid of those people
and if your P&L is upside down there's a
leader that is not paying attention to
the numbers so all these problems are
gonna be leadership problem so if you
want to improve your business well then
what you need to do is improve your
leadership now I will say this as well I
just got to make like a little caveat
here cuz you just talked about the value
of it if you're out there in the world
and you can't afford to come to the
muster which I understand the monster is
expensive it costs us a lot to put
together I had somebody hit me up like
hey it sounds like you care a bit more
about making money I was like no no we
definitely want to make money that's
what that's we are business and we need
to make money and we need to pay our
team and so yeah we are we're gonna make
money and the monster is expensive it
cost a lot of money if you can't afford
to come to the monster don't come to the
muster if you can't don't go out and
borrow money to come to the muster no
you you you're not you you know don't
skip a mortgage payment so you can come
to the muster that's not a good idea
what you do is you implement some
financial discipline you start saving
money you put it together and you can
come to the next muster by the way if
you can't afford the muster you can get
a book called extreme ownership it costs
1697 on Amazon that's fine we this
podcast is free there's 400 something
hours of us talking about this kind of
thing so you can do that like I said
wait if you can come to the monster
that's where you're gonna get basically
a private jujitsu lesson you're gonna
learn really granular things you're
gonna get the interaction face-to-face
you're gonna get to ask the specific
questions about your world and you're
gonna interact with people that are on
the same path as you that's awesome if
you can come come we'll see you at the
muster that no green room thing mm-hmm
we've talked about that before but
that's that's a big deal that's a bigger
deal than it might seem because you know
how like how you said like okay you have
a Q&A part or you know like you know you
have a specific question like hey that
was cool what you just said but what
about that you know like some people
have questions so during the break when
most times I get these convinced
whatever they got but you know the
people they'll say their what they have
to send then they'll go and they'll
disappear
straight up distribution their covers on
their eyes yeah whatever grapes whatever
and but here it's like people like hey
that question that I had now I can go
run and go go grab lei for duck or
whatever and ask it like personally yeah
it's what we have when during the break
Lafe and i were on stage yeah the break
we say okay take a break come back in 12
minutes we step down off the stage and
we stand right there and people just
come and ask us more questions and we
continue talking and sometimes eight
somebody has such a good question we're
like bring it back and we're back on
stage and say hey someone just asked
this question here's the question it's a
great question you know it's wrong yeah
the whole time the whole time yeah yeah
even looking in the in this would happen
to me a lot for some reason they think I
know well I guess I couldn't know a
little bit I'm gonna ask you the
leadership questions always a game like
in the hallway you know the best thing
to do in that situation is you want to
discuss yeah that's I was gonna say
that's one of the other primaries to
come to musters EKKO Charles is gonna be
there one of these days we're gonna get
you on stage for a keynote presentation
sure and it's gonna be awesome
yeah you're gonna be right right in your
comfort zone getting flanked alright
moving on those are the three questions
about the muster but they got asked so
here knowing what you know about war and
the teams if you could go back in time
what would you have done differently man
I wish I could go back in time Dave
Burke and I were doing an event earlier
this week and he was he said you know
I'm glad I'm not Romani I know life
probably wishes he wasn't Ronnie
100% I go there right now yeah let's go
and look it's what I would do
differently is the recognition that we
were super aggressive we took a lot of
risk what I would do differently is I
would actually be even more aggressive I
would be a hundred times more aggressive
I would be putting up you know a concept
of operations brief for your for your
approval to send up the chain to swim
across the river and hit targets and and
and you know put in some cyber over
watches and
completely ruin the bad guys program
going on in south-central my when they
had complete freedom movement before
they had any expectation that we could
be there before I could get to us and I
think they would never see it coming
which means that we would have more
impact and it would actually be safer
for us because they wouldn't be
expecting it so they were probably
hammers but we recognized that we could
get away with a lot more you know that
then we could and looking back on it I
just when you when you come into an area
they're like hey don't go in there
you're all gonna get killed you you want
to be cautious you don't want to just
jump into things you want to mitigate
risk and control certainly but we
recognized we could get away with a lot
more than we thought we could and and
more often than not bring bring guys
home and of course that's the one thing
I would change obvious if I could change
if I would trade places with Mark Lee
and ride Joe in my platoon in a second I
trade places with Mike Monsour and Delta
in a second and I don't wish I could do
that and I can't but that is a that is
what I would change but I certainly
would if we could go back there again we
would be even more aggressive and we'd
have even more impact there's a term
that that they used to say and the teams
I don't know if you ever heard it you
probably did when we be doing special
reconnaissance training and guys would
say trust your camouflage did you ever
hear that expression you may not have I
don't wanna listen so what it was was
when you got good at putting your
camouflage together you could really get
aggressive in getting up and observing a
target because if you trust your camel
if you've done a good job with your kami
paint your ghillie suit and and putting
yourself together well the enemy's not
gonna be able to see you but it's really
weird to be you know 40 meters from a
target that you're looking at then
there's a guy walking around and you
feel completely naked like they can see
but they can't see you at all they can't
see you at all and so it takes some it
takes some time to learn to trust your
camouflage and I think you know
obviously hindsight is 20/20 and when
you look back at your Mahdi like you
look back and you think yourself we
could have done this we could have done
that we could have gotten closer that
target we could've done more things
because our hindsight's 20/20 and also
we learned over time to trust our
camouflage and the longer we were there
the the more of
recive you know operations took place
but yeah let's hindsight's 20/20 isn't
it that it is okay advice on restarting
your life after the military I think you
just got to figure out what you want to
do yeah you gotta figure I have a new
mantra that I tell people now it's it's
a find your next mission and that's what
you got to do it I got really lucky
because got right into this and you you
the same thing like we we went right
into a new mission and so anytime to
kind of wander around and look around
and figure out which direction to go and
by the way when you're wandering around
and looking around to find out which
direction to go you're gonna get pulled
in the direction and that direction is
probably gonna be the path of least
resistance it's not gonna be a good path
when you certainly know it's not gonna
be the path so when you come out when
you get out of the military man have a
mission figure out what your next
missions gonna be but I would disagree
there and that it wasn't that we'd got
lucky right in that and that if you
think about what we're doing now this is
what we like to do and this is what we
we we brought lessons back from Maudie
that we we translated and gave to the
next generation of seals and and saw the
impact that was have I mean when you
when you came back from I you could have
had any any job that you wanted to and
you said I want to go run training
detachment because I want to make sure
that the the the next seals that are
coming through this training and going
forward a places like Iraq Afghanistan
are ready you chose to do that and I was
running a training program that that's I
would I didn't want to be anywhere else
in that it was awesome and I recognize
how powerful that was and the kind of
reward it brought to me to see these
young officers go out there that I put
through training and succeed on on
incredibly difficult dangerous
battlefields in different areas that
I've been to so you know we we took that
and recognize that this is something
that that that is useful it has impact
and and that we can do for others so I
think that's it was absolutely not the
path of least resistance and I got you
know we had job offered offers that
people thought people thought I was
completely crazy a buddy miners like
come work for me will pay you this huge
salary that was you know triple what
Navy salary was and I said I'm not gonna
do that I'm gonna start my own business
and he looked at me like I was nuts yeah
we were talking about yesterday cuz we
weren't making a lot of money at the
beginning of echelon front now are we
yeah yeah we were we we had to put
together we were writing checks and
paying for things and traveling on our
own dime to to go and talk to companies
and for free for free yeah for almost
nothing
yeah and I think that's the and that's
really it is is finding your mission
like this is what I can do and this is
this is what I like to do and and I'm
gonna figure out a way to do something
that is useful it impacts people and I
think that's that's ricki is fine in
that next mission for sure next question
I like this question this this question
made me think that whoever wrote this
question has a good feel for like kind
of the whole thing here so the question
was he's this question to life
what's Jacko's most impactful strategy
on you when he says life gets real fired
up definitely someone who's been
listening to a lot of podcasts or maybe
he's coming to muster hurt hurt us
speaker top before cuz Jocko talks about
angry late relay every day I can get
angry
that's like hothead right basically be a
little bit of a hothead
I can definitely be a hot air you can be
a lot a bit about it forever I can't and
usually I mean I I'd like to think that
it takes me I don't immediately spend up
on things but once I get spun up I get a
really spun up and I don't know if you
disagree no no I agree
you know I was gonna ask you is is is
house having two kids for sure that that
teaches you some temper control big-time
big-time and it in particularly when you
know when there's there's timelines
you're trying to meet and we're trying
to run a business they don't they just
know the timeline is now I want some
crayons now and without what I've loved
is I love spending time with my son and
uh and my daughter on their awesome kids
and protecting my son now he's Three's
old enough to cut you know he's in the
game yeah we'll go we'll go somewhere it
do something fun or we're hanging out
and it doesn't matter if that's five
minutes long or five hours long like
when it's time to leave it's level
nineteen meltdown
every time right and he I'm waiting for
the time he's like dad thank you for the
time another thought doesn't happen so
so yeah that actually instills and use
some some patience some patience but
it's the we always talk about red flags
and that's something that I learned from
you and that I know you were looking at
for me to see like Oh some red flags are
going off red flags are those things
that as you talked about often you
recognize in yourself like okay I'm
getting spun up right now I need to take
a step back here and and and throttle
back I need to throttle back or examine
get spun up so so with kids I got a look
at it as you know what this is good cuz
cuz I know that some of it's in my
nature that I can get spun up so with
kids I gotta relish that opportunity to
say this is a training opportunity for
me to be outside of my comfort zone to
say oh you know what I feel myself
getting spun up I'm gonna practice
detaching and spinning down and not not
reacting in a way that I might otherwise
would have and I think it's a great it's
a great tool they're really from for me
I think what the when Jocko would sense
that in me and we've talked about a
number of times when that's happened
here on the podcast that I was getting
spun up you know we talked about you
know previous in previous pot guys about
canceled the app and some of these
things where I you know I just I would I
would get fired alive and get angry and
and you what most be watered down in
that situation what I probably would
have done to a subordinate leaders is
get is is get spun up as well and but
you yell at me now I'm gonna yell at you
but a little bit louder exactly and how
we're gonna ramp up and it becomes like
the battle of wills and and how you hand
you handle that except sit well with me
was generally you would what you would
never get someone up you would just be
very calm with your response and you
would ask questions or in some cases you
would just start chuckling like like
laughing about it like hey then you get
smart and not not no way that you're
understanding you're not like oh yeah it
was in a way I don't want to laugh at
people when they're getting mad yeah
amen take it easy yeah just take it easy
and then you start laughing at anybody
it was and then it just that was
something that was what would you ask
questions in a way that were hey well
why why do you think this her and those
thing that was powerful as well to me
that wasn't it wasn't like hey
are you doing this or why won't you
listen to me and it was that always
allowed me to kind of take a step back
and recognize okay so I think you got to
make sure you see a red flag at somebody
else they're getting spun up and they're
really emotional you need to be
unemotional and you need to you need to
check your ego to do an end-around I
never see anybody do that before you did
exceptionally well against me and and I
learned a lot from that because I
recognized like I got to do that better
and it never it just doesn't benefit you
from getting spun up and angry and I'll
tell you one thing that's another little
thing that I noticed that I do for sure
is if someone comes at me and they're
super mad about something I can't just
be a hundred percent calm because if if
you come in the room and you co chalk
all this crap the we're getting told to
do this thing over this is total crap
pushing man told to do this and if I go
Lafe just calm down
it's not that big of a deal like right
there I've already taken right cuz
you're like what are you talking about
something I try that with my wife it
doesn't work the opposite what you have
is you have to be you have to show some
uh-uh
we'll call it a diminished reflection of
the emotion that they're showing you
wanna you want to take a little off of
it but you know all my labor you serious
they're telling us to do that oh man
that's that's that's crap alright listen
let's find out what's going on so now
instead of being against you now all of
a sudden on your side I've calmed down a
little I've brought you down a little
bit but you at least recognize that I'm
on your side because if I just if I just
say wave calm down
getting mad is not gonna help oh look
like you're gonna get even matter or if
I say you need to think about what
they're saying no no I need to join your
side first once I'm on your side now we
can talk and we can move through the
problem effectively so you might want to
just show a little diminished reflection
of the PERT of you know if someone's
really sad about something okay you know
you can't just be like hey it's not that
big of a deal like hey you know I got a
girl I got kids right I got I got
teenage girls and you know they get sad
about stuff and I can't just you know
I've tried it before like don't worry
about that
it will mean nothing in three years I've
done that look by the time you graduate
high school you won't even think about
that anymore
stop how does that work it doesn't work
good because you realize that that's the
whole world to them so you know instead
you got to say hi man
I can't believe that happened you know
that's that's that's sad you know but
the good thing is here's some good
points about it and maybe you know what
I mean
so just don't be completely emotionless
because then the person can't relate to
the you and if they can't relate to you
you're not gonna be able to talk about
it if you can't talk about it you're not
gonna make any progress on the subject
be careful with that one all right I
want to hear more HDH in Vegas did we
talk about the HDH hands on one of the
other podcasts yeah we talked about it's
$100 listen to podcast 11 if you want to
hear about Mark Lee so our shenanigans
in Vegas we did have there were a couple
of good stories of Vegas we you know we
that was a crazy boondoggle try but one
of them that I did remember well was we
had this giant convoy of Humvees and we
were coming up to a major intersection
just off the Vegas Strip a red light
because we were driving to several knows
we're driving we drove the Humvees to
arrange to do work up in that area uh-uh
there's an air force range Nellis no
service so it was an Ellis range where
they do training up there and we had
taken the Humvees from one base on
civilian roads to another base and we'd
spent the day training there and now it
was time to come back to base so we're
back on civilian roads again in a in a
convoy of Humvees what five trucks
probably so five Humvees and we had done
a drill where we had that we I was
always big on you train how you fight
right so that means if we're driving
Humvees guess what we're doing we're
mounting weapons we're gonna we're gonna
be ready to get after it if we have to
not that we have to get after in Vegas
but we're gonna we're gonna test things
because if you're not used to swinging
that gun around up in the up in the
turret then you're not used to it so
you've got a practice so we were
basically in in full kind of kit I think
we actually had the whole task in us I
think we had like eight or ten Humvees
it was it was a big boy yeah but yeah so
we come up to we're coming up to a red
light the red light starts to turn
yellow and the lead the lead navigator
this is a major intersection you know to
four-lane roads that are coming up
coming up to he gives the command below
through which means that we're just if
you get you're an ambush and people are
shooting at you and you're just going to
keep rolling and he's
blow through so we literally have the
entire convoy behind him like running
this red light at a major intersection
yeah I was like we're gonna be standing
tall from we don't want to do that
because in like in Iraq you wouldn't
stop at a red light or you wouldn't stop
but it stops on you you know you
obviously the lead vehicle would check
close enough and then you you're
traveling really tight and you make sure
there's no cars coming but yeah you're
just gonna blow for you're not gonna
stop and so that the other call came out
to so much trouble for them it would've
been a fight well luckily we had some
heads-up drivers that stopped that the
their green light and saw us coming or
maybe they were intimidated by guys with
50 Cal machine guns and the turret but
definitely you know that's one of those
things where it's hard for guys to turn
it off sometimes and when you're when
you're doing tactical driving on the
range as if you were in a combat
scenario and all of a sudden you're on
the street yes yeah again
this is hard I should have been said
okay guys we're going back on civilian
roads stand down you know what I mean I
should have said that but I didn't say
that
because I'm dumb and I we we made the
assumption which turned out to be false
and that people would automatically know
that and they didn't yeah so so we had
to tighten that up but that was just I
wanted one lesson learned provide our
biggest trick that was shenanigans yeah
it was good times
I'm surprised I didn't get more trouble
for that one of the one of your guys we
were in a he was a designated driver
we're in a Navy van and we go from one
place we knew someone and we were out
out in town and we went from there to
downtown to go to you know the bars
right in Vegas we're pulling into a
parking garage and you know they have
that metal pipe that says you know six
foot two inch clearance or whatever the
clearance was it was a very low parking
garage so he's got this big Navy van we
come in and we we kind of hit that and
I'm sitting in the back and you know
what this is a classic example of a
decentralized command I'm not gonna step
on the toes the guy's the designated
driver I wasn't drinking I had a few
drinks or whatever but I wasn't
definitely wasn't intoxicated and but I
see Oh like I look out and I see well we
kind of hit that thing and so we go
around the corner and then we start to
actually enter the parking garage and as
we go underneath the first
concrete beam the the it's you can hear
it scrapes against the ceiling and if it
scrapes hard and the vehicle comes to a
stop and what does the driver do again
this is the designated driver what does
he do he starts pressing down the gas
he's just gonna power I'm in the back I
go dude dude what are you doing stop
what are you gonna rip the roof off of
the vehicle like back out of here and
leave music will thought I could have
made it one one gig team guys
shenanigans that we were talking about
was me you and the Delta Commander Delta
platoon commander rollin rollin up to
Santa Barbara I think you actually came
up to me and said tenacious d are you
gonna seat tenacious d yeah so for those
of you may not know Jocko is a huge
tenacious d fan the d now I think that's
that's how it came out you're like the D
there in Santa Barbara let's go road
trip road trip road gig Road gig so we
jumped in yeah of all the things that we
you gave me he gave me a copy of a bow
faced by david hackworth when we were
working together to you bruiser at the
end of our art our tour together and you
gave me the this set to the the DVDs to
tenacious d and the Duggars oh that's
the dichotomy of leadership right there
and Hackworth about-face the tenacious d
yeah so we found that tenacious d he was
having a concert up in Santa Barbara you
know we're all stationed here at San
Diego and and we jumped in Jacko's dodge
Greta 1997 Dodge Grand Caravan 1997 a
lot of people just called it the pimp
wagon because it was hard to keep the
ladies off we're old and this is the
window is tape shot on the driver's side
its riggers tape shot karna you weren't
getting in there no that thing was shut
because a little electrical thing broke
so we're we're we're cheap mastered so
we're not gonna spend the night up there
I think we actually had work to do maybe
the next day so we took we jump in the
van Jack I think you drove up there we
rock out to Tenacious D concert in Santa
Barbara we we bought Jocko a t-shirt
forgot it the Sasquatch is real the
Sasquatch is real and I I remember
driving back at about there's about 3
o'clock in the morning we were like
passing through camp peddled and that's
kind of where our ranges are there as
all the way back down with just acapella
singing to every Tenacious D zone that
we knew my heart we're gonna make a new
band it's gonna be called
acapella D that was a good dub yeah yeah
that was pretty fun all right
tenacious d what are your daily
non-negotiable habits wave Babin my
daily non-negotiable habits usually I
want to sleep in about 10:30 10:30 a.m.
Evan style just eat some donuts listen I
mean I the end of the day just when he
goes freedom it's a mantra that I
learned from you and that it's just
absolutely true and if you got it
you got to get up in the morning and
work out there's some days I frankly I
can't do that because life gets in a way
whether I'm if I'm traveling or my kid
wakes up early and I know I've been out
of town and my wife wants to get a
workout in before the day starts oh I'll
take the kids so she can do that and we
can we can rotate out you know so I
can't tell you that always happens but
you got to get up early you got to work
out and you have to you have to
prioritize and that's cute and having
that checklist that you put together the
night before about what you want to do
and what's important is is absolutely
critical otherwise you lose it and you
know for me and Jocko and for all of us
in our team on national on front like
it's when we get away from the things
that we talk about the people we're
human beings like everybody else I mean
you get pulled in different directions
when we get away from those things it
doesn't work things start to fall apart
you lose you lose track of where the
priorities all right if I can't
regularly detach that's something I have
to really focus on to do is is to
regularly detach if I'm grinding on
something for two or three or four hours
at a time sometimes it's easy to miss
other things that are better coming up
and I got to make sure I pull away from
things kind of kind of think about the
priority
nice cute peace figure out you know if I
need to reprioritize and so I don't get
target fixated on one thing and and keep
going but I think for me you know I what
I want to do is I try to make time to
spend time with my family as much as I
can as well and obviously there's
there's a there's a lot of work to do
there always is and and it's you know
those things the the the one when when I
could stay consistent on getting up
early in the morning getting a workout
in you know stay focused on a list that
I have from the night before that I'm
falling through all the things that you
talk about
that's I'm performing better than I ever
do when it works at the end of it is
what works and there's what doesn't work
yeah that's how you win check tell us
about a time you were annoyed with Jocko
or his intensity annoyed with Jocko or
his intensity you know what we we got
along pretty damn well together and and
I think there's not there's not really
any time that comes to mind that I was
annoyed by you except for maybe you know
what would have mentioned earlier right
when the times when initially we were
working together and you're looking over
my shoulder and and telling me to do a
we should do this way let's let's let's
plan it like that that I definitely got
got annoyed from that time I felt like I
want to run my you know everyone's
trying to tell me what to do here and
Jacques was looking over my shoulder and
I want to run run my team just as
explained earlier and and I didn't
realize until later like what you were
doing and like hey you're you're passing
you're passing on a lot of great
information and I see that all the time
actually with people because if I could
have detached from that situation I
would have recognized like hey I'm a new
platoon commander I've never been at
Patoka Manor Jaco was just double toe
commander he had a highly successful
platoon commander to her he had a
historic deployment where he did a whole
bunch operations and he's got a ton of
lessons learned so what an amazing
opportunity to learn everything from him
but that's not the way you approaches
right it's like an ego my ego and I see
that all the time and there was there
was a leader a leader I was dealing with
where I was talking to a member of the
board for this particular leader who was
constantly bucking against the you know
this guys and I it was it's amazing to
me to see like hey the the CEO of this
company is pushing back and
the board like he should be so thankful
that the member of the board has who's
got massive amounts of experience
extraordinary success is is there to
mentor and train him and yet he doesn't
want to listen to that guy I want to do
with myself
you're always over my shoulder instead
of being like hey man open up the legal
pad let's take some notes here I want I
want to pick your brain for everything I
want you know it's and and I think just
recognize if you're feeling that way and
you're frustrated with with somebody
who's looking over your shoulder then
then you need to take advantage of the
situation to learn from them and
certainly build up trust them oh the way
to get out of that situation is to build
up trust to show that you you're
learning you're growing and and that you
don't need someone to look over your
shoulder every second and usually that
comes even after we got forward and you
just Unleashed us on the battlefield I
would always come to you me I hate
soccer what do you think about this
we're gonna do this situation I wasn't
looking to you to tell me what to do
but I was running things behind and we
do that all the time now that's not
front like I call jacoba say hey here's
what's going on I'm working on this
leader you do the same I mean we talk
about these things all the time and well
and that it's actually that what's
what's interesting about that is that in
the last six months that ideas really
become formalized in the tank which is
where we take the companies that were
working with and we whoever's working
specifically with us with a specific
company on the ground is coming back to
the tank all the national on front team
and we we get on the call or the Skype
or the conference room and we go through
all the issues that all these different
companies are having and that's where we
solve the problems is in the tank so
that way we get everyone's input and not
only do we give the best solution to the
client we also all learn from it so that
we have that solution in our head so be
we all get stronger and better so that's
that's one of the evolutions of national
on front that's pretty awesome to see is
what started off as just like how we
would run to you bruiser which is hey
we're gonna bounce ideas off each other
and hey I don't know how to solve this
problem to you or hey I don't know how
to do this operation to you or this is
what I think what do you think which is
the way a team should work together and
now what we do is we get to do that for
other companies use the same brain power
use the same methodology and it's it's
awesome to do and it's awesome to see it
is awesome
the tank yeah getting in the tank
all right Leif you were the fuzzy that
don't know life was a ship driver for
how many years before you so labor atomy
didn't get picked up for seagull teams
right outro didn't get picked up for
buds right out of the Naval Academy so
he had to go to a ship here's a question
about not about that specifically but
Lafe what are your thoughts on a ship's
captain being relieved of command and
what to do if you are involved and he
would like to know from the ships
captain's perspective that is being
relieved because of the mistakes of your
crew or if you're in the crew and the
captain's getting were getting relieved
even though you made the mistakes what
do you order your perspectives on that
well look just to give people some
background on that I know I've talked
about my background on podcast 11 but
but it was I never wanted to be a ship
job I want to be a CEO that's why I
wanted the naval Cammy I got thrust in
that position looking back on it it was
it was an amazing opportunity for me as
a young man to have to be in those
leadership positions and I joined my
time on this a warship cost to build
billion Billy a couple billion dollars
Tracey so your your your sometimes
you're the guy right you're a lieutenant
JG on the bridge of a two billion dollar
ship and you're in charge of all yeah
and when you're when you're the officer
of the deck you're the guy in charge the
captain's asleep right in his cabin and
he's got all full faith and trust in you
and you're running the ship and so
there's the question right there
sometimes the captain's a chef asleep in
the cabin and he runs in and the crew
runs the ship aground the captain gets
fired what do you think about that that
is the Navy way it's it's always been
that way
and I think it's 100% correct because
there are no bad teams only bad leaders
and I think that if you have even if the
captain wasn't in direct responsibility
it's his job to train that team it's his
job to mentor that team and if he's got
questions about whether or not somebody
is has the capability to do that job
then then they shouldn't be in that
position it's up it's a it's up it's up
to the cabin now the captain can't be
everywhere at once to it's decentralized
command he has to rely on his leaders
but it's it's definitely I think
ultimately the the captain is
responsible and that's really what
dream ownerships I had a client ask me a
question yesterday have you ever sent
anyone to do something that they weren't
ready to do and I thought about it for a
minute and the first thought was well of
course the second thought was no the
real answer is it's a gray area right
did I ever send somebody to do something
that they weren't 100% if I put this
quantification on a hundred percent
ready for it all the time all the time
how often did I send somebody to do
something that they weren't capable of
doing the answer is zero in other words
if you weren't capable of doing this and
I didn't trust that you could make it
happen I wasn't gonna let you do it
that'd be irresponsible for me as a
leader to let a subordinate go and do
something that they're not ready to do
that's it period or they're not 100%
ready to do or they're no not a hundred
they're not capable of doing but I mean
when we first got to Ramadi in your mind
you probably weren't 100% ready to go
out there and execute in particular cuz
we've been training for a mission with
just seals you know for roll-up assaults
or direct action raids you know that
night time and all of a sudden were
shift into daytime counterinsurgency
operations working with Iraqi soldiers
completely different missions yeah
broken up in all these different units
we had trained we hadn't trained like
that in a violent war zone by the way
but I you know I had trust that you were
completely competent and capable of
doing that and if I didn't think that
and I didn't think you were competent or
I didn't think you were capable then I
would I would be a bad leader if I said
yeah go ahead and go to go do that and
and then I answered the question further
to this client I said there was two
people from tasking a bruiser that
didn't go on deployment with us because
they weren't capable of doing that job
so yes you as a leader you're
responsible and I was think about this
there's been times where Navy ships have
run aground and the captain wasn't even
on board he had flown to somewhere to go
do a meeting somewhere the ship runs
aground guess what still getting fired
because you left someone in charge that
you left that team you didn't train them
well enough and you can make all the
excuses you want I wasn't there
yeah well guess what you're still
getting fired because you were
responsible for that team I think part
of that too is the understanding you
know what no bad team zone bad leaders
that would the chapter two we wrote you
know it
extreme ownership is about the part of
that is I have seen some people that
misinterpret that right to say well I
got a bad leader so the team's not good
that that's not an excuse so when we're
talking about leadership we're talking
about leaders at every level of the
organization so so you know if you're if
you're if you're a department head on
that ship or a division officer or a
division chief and you say oh I got a
bad I got a bad commanding officer it's
all the commanding officers fault our
ship doesn't doesn't perform the way it
should
whatever your team is that's not an
excuse you got to do your utmost to get
your team ready to train others around
you and lead that team as much as you
possibly can it you don't have to be the
senior guy in charge and offer some of
the best units we work with and we're
part of the senior guy may not he man up
in the get driving the operations but he
allowed his leaders to go out and
execute and and make it happen so
leadership we're talking we're talking
leaders at every level the organization
it's not an excuse to put the blame on
the boss you got to step up you got a
lead and own your team solve problems
get better learn for mistakes and make
it happen what does it mean when the
ship runs aground I mean literally it's
dirt oh well in this case we're talking
ship collisions yeah so running aground
is one thing the you know and there's an
argument there is an argument to be said
like because some of our greatest
leaders like Admiral Fleet Admiral
Chester Nimitz who was the hero of the
Pacific War was I've quoted him you know
on this on this podcast previously he
was the commander in chief of all US
forces in the Pacific so he was he was
the the person responsible for the
entire war effort against the Japanese
in World War two and in that victory a
massive effort obviously in an
extraordinary turnaround from from
disaster to to victory he actually ran a
ship aground as a junior officer so so
there's you know there's an argument to
be made that there is no II know the
flawless performance it doesn't exist
and people make mistakes you can learn
from it you know as far as ships running
around you know that that's one thing I
think you know you can make a careful
evaluation what we're talking about here
that is facilities that ship collisions
and you know those those should not
happen that just that should not happen
I understand how easily that
happen because it's it there's a these
are huge machines that go very fast and
you're out on the ocean with other other
ships that are moving around and there's
a whole lot of dangerous things some of
those big ships takes miles to stop them
like even if you see and you go okay hit
all full brakes right now it doesn't
matter
you're still gonna hit absolutely you
know you're gonna get hit for like ten
minutes yep you know it's you can't stop
it
just brace for impact yeah but but if
you've got you got the right team in
place they know they're you know there's
all kinds of safe safeguards in place
and if that team's properly trained like
that should not happen it should not
it's like you should be able to the
airplane should land safely all the
horrible things that could go wrong when
you're flying an airplane and landing in
a crazy airport like JFK or you know our
LAX in Hong Kong
yeah that's a doozy too yeah so those
kind of things that are crazy so but
there's a lot of things to go wrong but
if it's done properly and safeguards in
place you're gonna you're gonna be fine
so so it so but there's again it doesn't
mean that yeah we expect flawless
performance that no one's ever gonna
make mistakes I think if a mistake isn't
that bad it should be forgiven but there
isn't there just isn't an excuse of like
well it wasn't me
somebody else on my team did it that's
the opposite of extreme ownership it
doesn't work doesn't work check next I
this is relate well I guess yeah yes it
is for life I heard you say it is
important to think I heard Jacko's say
this too how do you think meaning how do
you talk to yourself do you ask yourself
questions do you think by talking to
others what do you believe is the most
valuable method for becoming a clear
thinker and communicator that's a deep
question I actually think it's pretty
easy to answer it is easy answer I think
I can answer in one word go detach
that's that's that's how I think you you
can't you got to step out you got to
step back
mentally you got to step back look at
what's going on and think of and that's
where you can think about it that's
where you can figure out what's going on
if you can do that you're there if you
can't do it you don't even know you're
not doing it that's the problem when
you're not detached you don't even know
you're not attached you're in the storm
and you don't even know it that's out
for that's
exactly right I think you know for
people that maybe don't fully understand
what that means right the this idea of
the tassel which you've obviously talked
a lot about on here and which is such a
key thing for decision-making it's the
the I think the key thing there is is to
make sure that you're not you're not
clouded by you know this emotional
attachment to plans which we often
talked about with our leaders and the
SEAL team so I am emotionally invested
in a plan that I came up with I spent
hours or days or weeks or months you
know involved in and I want that to
succeed of course but but is that you
know I gotta have that realistic
assessment and that's what the
detachment really requires is that you
pull yourself not just physically away
you know out of the weeds are to say
okay let me think about this in the
strategic picture but you really you
take away that emotional investment that
you have to to maybe even whether it's a
plant sometimes it's a team member as
well and if you have you know someone
that you just have a close relationship
with that you you know that whether
they're our relative of yours or you had
a long-standing relationship with and
and that maybe you've gotten too close
to them and you can't see that that you
know they become more important in the
mission and they're dragging the rest of
the team down you're not making the call
either tighten them up or let them go if
that's that's the right case so I think
what that really requires is you got
emotionally pull back it's a it's a it's
a mental thing to really have a brutally
honest assessment of the situation
that's that's independent from any kind
of previous bias that you might have had
that's interesting there because even if
you know like oh yeah I'm gonna detach
oh not that easy yeah like you go
through the motions and you can't be
like hey I'm gonna detach I'm detached
right now meanwhile you're just like I
said clouded by the emotional part that
you're like kind of one foot in
emotionally so you're technically not
detached so it doesn't work you know
what else is a good way to think is to
listen you listen what people are saying
I've been thinking about how more how he
said if you listen you know twice as
much you know everything that you know
and you know everything that the other
guy knows that's a great that's a great
thing but if you're sitting in a you
know conversation I mean from a business
perspective if you're in a meeting and
and there's a conversation going on if
you're in the conversation you're
talking you're adding your
peace well then you're you're not
detached you're in it but if you sit
back and you listen and you hear what's
going on you can assemble you know
thoughts better so all right next when
can we expect any books to come out by
either of you and what are they going to
be like extreme ownership or way of the
warrior kid so I also had a book out
called discipline equals freedom it's a
field manual by the way sure you
familiar with the field manual I know
you claim to be familiar with Field
Manual that's favorite kind of man yeah
okay way the warrior Kid 2 is coming out
in April it's called Marc's mission and
we are in the process of writing
Lafe babban tell me about that yes we
are we're getting after a second book
right now to follow on book two extreme
ownership and I'm super excited about
it's it's it's gonna be in the same
format when we talk about combat combat
lessons learned on the battlefield or in
training and then a principle and then
its application of the business world
and the same in the same format extreme
ownership and what it really is is it's
to answer all of the questions and
difficulties that people have from
applying the principles we get these
common questions all the time of like
okay I'm having this issue it okay you
said take ownership here but but what
does that really mean and how do I apply
a cover moves you know to my team these
it's gonna dive much deeper into that
and it's it's gonna be also gonna be
coming out fall of 2018 how do you feel
about writing a sequel it's it's not a
sequel it's gonna be a standalone look
on its own it's gonna be good okay I
think it's nerve-wracking because you
know what have you ever seen the movie
Jaws yes yes that's one of my favorite
movies have you ever seen the movie Jaws
- yes we got issues with jaws - we got
issues yeah and this is what I think so
I think again I'll call it luck he maybe
not but I call it luck luckily for us
this book has sold really well that if
we would have written a sequel a year
after this book came out it would have
been jaws - to be
but luckily during because now it's been
two years since this came out so we've
had and by the way a follow-up year if
we would have released a book if the
publisher is going release another book
release another book you will pay you
more money that's what they do they want
you to release another book now we got
some hype from this book we'll get
another one out there and laugh and I
were like well no not right now just
stop and we'll that time that we write
another book well I did write another
book but they're not the same right we
don't we want we don't want to make jaws
too so we let time go and guess what
we're doing all the time that we that we
had past right we weren't sitting around
no we were working with more companies
we were working with more military units
we were working with police we were
working firefighters we were having the
muster we were learning more and more
lessons and we were getting feedback
from this book and saying okay I see
some threads and at first it was one
little thread and it was another little
thread and now all of a sudden all those
threads come together and you get
something you get you get fabric and
that's what we waited for is let's get
something that is a woven fabric has to
be strong like Kevlar so the next book
that we got coming out I disagree with
you that's a standalone book I don't
think it's a standalone book are you
gonna retract your statement I'm gonna
give you a chance you should I do we've
tracked my statement because because it
is I mean the new book I thought you
were setting me up for an ambush there
no no it's I'm sure you could read the
new book on your on its own but you
shouldn't you should read extreme
ownership first and then you read the
new book and when you read the new book
it's gonna again all those threads are
gonna weave together and and and they're
gonna be the perfect it's gonna be
approved they're gonna complement each
other
amazing amazing way I think that's in
that and that method are and from that
perspective absolutely I think
absolutely it is it is a sequel in that
respect I it it will be written in a way
that that you can read it as a
standalone book for sure it was
certainly reference you know the things
that we talked about anystream ownership
and the foundational principles of
Homewood said that that's written I
think there are a few exceptions under
your jaw's analogy a lot actually
yeah I mean I can think that Indiana
Jones
the Temple of Doom yeah terminator yeah
Terminator 2 yeah a day but it does have
a lot to do with how you said it let's
wait a little bit yeah that's you can't
just unless the whole story thank you
difference it doesn't a difference
because if you just oh we had a hit
movie make another one right right cause
- yeah that's a good title Jaws was a
hit let's make another one we'll call it
jaws - yeah if they would have waited
like terminator they waited at what
eight years or so then it's like okay a
lot of things are updated a lot of new
stuff they figured out you're like oh
you're saying that boom Terminator -
just as good aliens aliens
the first movie was that pretty quick
afterwards the second movie aliens
crushed the person movie really the I to
be totally honest it's a gamble though
no I actually I don't know cuz I'm I'm
half way a little bit more than halfway
done with my writing part right before
we start editing each other I think I
think we might have an a sequel that's
better I don't know I I have a suspicion
that the sequel is better possibly
better I think so too it's but it's
super fun to write as we're doing it I
think as you said our knowledge is so
much more now I mean we our knowledge of
the business world was was we've been
working for a couple you know two or
three years and this is where all that
point but but now we've got double more
than double that and and the reach and
expansion of what we've been doing since
the release of extreme ownership is it's
it's a hundred x what we were doing you
know previously so that's just given us
it's been a massive education and and
our knowledge of how to apply these
things across the spectrum yeah is
incredibly so much so much deeper than
than it was previously and I'm excited
about yeah it's gonna be good next
question is how long does it take to
prepare for a muster and when when we
read this question earlier I thought it
was the person asking how long would
take this individual me or whoever a
person out in the world to get ready to
go to the muster oh yeah
and the answer to that is it doesn't
take you any time you just I mean you
should read extreme ownership for sure
but there's no like big physical there
there's physical things that you do with
the muster but they're scaled that
anybody can do them so it's really you
don't need to do any major preparation
of
then put your ego in check I think the
biggest progression you need is to look
at yourself in the mirror and and write
down look that where your weakest and
where you need to work I mean that's
what we want to talk I don't care what
you're doing great
we're not there to patch on the back we
want to care like where you can get
better and everyone can get better
certainly you can prove all the time and
I think that's what you need to do I
thought this questions about how we prep
for the muster which is about it's
always bone which is substantial always
about life about me all the time yeah
it's it's it is a ton of work to prepare
for the muster but which is it's fun
yeah it's fun it's it's great we do it
random question in your experience have
you had or do you see high injury rates
in jujitsu want to start rolling again
but don't want to disrupt progress on
the barbell Barba oh yeah it's
impossible I am being a weak socket
although not probable risk assessment
what do you think can you get injured in
jujitsu yes
yeah just like he came injured you're
playing basketball
you'll get injured playing basketball
quicker than you did to a fence fourth
injury as far as it goes yeah I will the
key part about this question for me is
you want to keep making progress on the
barbell right yes you want to keep
getting stronger that's cool I want you
to be stronger but if you're super
strong you don't know how to fight I got
nothing for you
yeah that's the deeper thing - and keep
this in mind knowing this goes for any
physical activity like if your goal
physically is this thing and then you
start going hard in another direction it
could very well take away from oh it's
you you're not gonna reach your maximum
potential as a lifter yeah if you're
doing jiu-jitsu you're swimming or
surgeries whatever yeah you got to find
the balance but I mean what's the most
important what's a more important skill
to have
yeah be able to snatch big weight or be
able to defend yourself in a street
fight yeah hey the snatching big weights
gonna help you defend yourself yeah big
we appreciate that
we're fans yeah but prioritize yeah now
what's interesting is on a daily basis I
always work out but I don't always do
jiu-jitsu because
you can't you need you need someone to
train with you know what I mean like you
need someone who'd you get to with you
can't do just by yourself yeah so
sometimes you don't have anyone to train
with look I think from my perspective as
a white belt it's it's I've trained
enough you got to be getting close to
that blue belts
well III got a lot more work to do
certain a lot more it's not up to him
you guys yeah that's true you guys have
inspired me I'm trying turning hard got
a got a great place I'm trying down in
Texas now John John Machado Austin's
awesome right yeah table whites are
white sauce yeah yeah if you're at all
now and it's the type of people that
train in there I mean it's it's and
that's that's what I like about that's
that that's you know same thing in the
place I trained in New York it's just
that to me has I think if you're
constantly getting engineer all the time
like you're not training with the right
people
and you're not training in the in the
right manner something that I learned
years ago and when I was on the boxing
team the Naval Academy me and my buddies
you know who were kind of scrubs we
didn't travel with the team but we just
beat the piss out of each other every
every day
and no one could breathe out of their
nose and everyone had black eyes and he
watched the guy who was the guys who
were really skilled they smart but they
were work on form there were you know
they they weren't just knocking each
other's heads off every punch every time
you know every single day and I think
that's it so that's where you have to
it's great to train hard but I think you
need to train smart and I think you need
to the biggest thing I'm guessing this
person is probably hasn't trained that
much so that they they spin out Dave
Burke and I were just rolling you know
here at victory last night
and I was I was I was telling a telling
Dave you know Dave he's made some
progress he's been training out in
Virginia I was like cool man you're
doing good but he gets so amped up that
he can't detach so he can't detach
because he's he's gets so amped up and
it's I realize I used to just be in that
I've trained enough now I still might be
the white belt see but I've trained
enough now to know that that I've got
I've got to throw all of that back
because it's yeah you get so focused
right I'm gonna focus on my one little
white belt americon I'm trying to get it
you know armbar versus versus like no
detach and think yeah so who trained
with him I yeah we did like yeah okay so
he it was funny as we're rolling around
at me is is
and in one point I'm like laughing him
because he's literally like you know
that kind of breathing like Dave in like
you know when you breathe when you feel
it hear somebody breathing hard like
that typically it's like when you're
there right in your ear so it's it
sounds way more intense this time could
have been also because I had a little
elbow pressure well the time period when
you're in my kind of starting jiu-jitsu
and Dave Burke might be in this
situation right now it's it's the very
early in jiu-jitsu where in your mind
you think like you know what like I'll
be able to I think I'll be able to get
like jockle right yeah sure like I'll be
like like you a man I think they learned
some little moving they're like oh if I
throw this at jockle at the right time
yeah there's at this black belt the
right time won't be able to get him yeah
you don't say yeah you have that vibrate
oh yeah for sure I had that with Dean
one time yeah I mean but what I when
you're amped up to that level though you
know and yeah you would you're thinking
that like no one can tap me or and I
don't think Dave's it isn't that in that
mode he's learned enough that maybe to
be levy on that but it's it's when
you're that amped up your chances of
getting injured or way work is more
significant and it's why you know if you
see a brand new white bill come I'd much
rather roll with brown belts and do even
though I know they're gonna you know
they're gonna get the best of me I I
have a much less chance of getting
injured than just the deathmatch with
some white belt is you know who doesn't
even know you know anything and and and
you so I think you got to be smart about
who you train with and that's what I
love about you know Jean Genet Machado
awesome with Todd why these guys they're
they're they're they're super you know
they're very knowledgeable they pass on
stuff with their humble just just like
just like folks here victory I mean it
it's and I think when you're training
with the right people they're like oh
cool you got you got me an armbar you
got to come or that choke was great show
me how to do that and it's it's a but
it's a Humboldt learning environment
where you know you're not there to
injure people you're not there to get
hurt and I think it's sure you're gonna
get tweaks and bumps and bruises but I
think there's you know if you're
training smartly and trying to learn
then the chance of getting injured the
probability is much less my boy Todd
what Todd white he's like old-school
jujitsu guy and he
me and him were on the circuit back
yesterday the compass back in the day he
was a la jean-jacques guy yeah and
anything by the way he listens to the
podcast by the way yeah la that's my
payments were fully yeah they were back
in the day alright oh I didn't do that
but Jiu Jitsu what even like I wouldn't
want to paint the picture that like all
white belts are gonna increase your
chance of injury it's it's kind of a
specific type of person around that will
increase your chance of injury and
that's like a guy who's strong may or
may not have like this ego word you
can't tell me and I'm gonna try to kill
him single time for sure and he has like
a in element of like legitimate strength
and athleticism on top of it so you
gotta put all those together like you go
into a typical gym all you take all the
white belts you may not even have a guy
like that that's true like the
probability of a guy being like that is
pretty low no no I disagree there might
be higher promising not pretty low
depends on what changes though in my
opinion what changes is that is the
barbell instructor like someone's bike
oh you want to get tough with that guy
over there well let me I'm gonna I'm
gonna impose some humility on you it's
called regulation yeah which is yet
another factor that kind of contributes
to the overall safety of it so and I'm
not saying low like they're rare nothing
like that what I'm saying if you take I
just don't know some random class a a
new white belt spazzy strong maybe may
or may not be young with like a huge ego
that maybe one guy me you won't get okay
a class full of those you know so your
day to day rolling is is pretty safe you
know I mean yeah you you do need to pick
your training partners carefully yeah
for sure but to this guy though here's I
mean it looked back when I go way back
I think I probably knew echo even before
before you did Jacqueline in our surface
warfare days I'm good good friend cake
nuts who's a mutual friend and others
that we've really worked with in fact
HECO was you were he was a bouncer
downtown no fine everyone knows because
he talks about
he had to put up with all our
shenanigans and back of the other
trouble list but I remember coming in
here at training at Victory and echo was
a blue belt and showing me and cake nuts
like some moves and and because I kind
of had this mentality of the guy who
asked this question of like you know you
might get injured and I was focused on
other things and I trained here all the
time and a lot of times I'd be here to
work out and I do stand up and I would
never I never trained you Jitsu like I
should have never stuck with it
consistently didn't have the discipline
to to do that for whatever reason I get
pulled in different directions and you
know here we are you know 10 or 12 years
later and echoes of brown belt she
knocking on the door of getting his
black belt and I'm still a white belt so
what door is he knocking on door getting
knocked on this silence out there so
don't be that guy I think I would make
the time to Train pretty good so yeah
for sure all right losing a teammate
both military and civilian civilian
world happens how do you assist and
promote healing and growth within a team
that has lost a pivotal member what do
you do when the emotional toll leaves
your guys unfocused and is creating
unacceptable risks yeah you know I've
talked about this this before and I
think obviously and this could happen
this is part of life is death and people
are gonna die and you obviously we're
all gonna deal it they're all going to
face it at some time you know work
environment how do you deal with it one
of the things that I always say is get
back to work right your yes you're gonna
mourn yes you're gonna have your
memorial services and then you got to
get back to work and I think if you let
people if you give them too much time
off if you let them sit around they're
gonna get unfocused they're gonna start
thinking about you know they're gonna
start thinking about things that are not
good to think about because we wanna yes
we want to mourn we want to do the we
want to remember but at the same time
and I say this all time we don't want to
dwell you don't want to dwell in the
past
you want to remember but don't dwell so
I say get back to work going back to
what we talked about earlier find out
what your next mission is gonna be you
have more of a reason to achieve your
mission because you lost someone that
you lost someone that can't in a gig
that can no longer carry on with their
mission so for them carry on with your
mission go forward don't dwell in the
past anybody that you lost that you
cared about what would they want you to
do what they want you to sit around and
sulk and look at the ground no they
don't want you to get your gear get your
mind set straight and get back after it
so that's what I recommend I think
that's that's exactly right and I think
getting to work the reason that's
important is if these people if that
person died you know and for the guys
that we lost like if we just if we just
gave up and walked away that means they
died in vain for nothing and and we're
not gonna do that we're gonna we're
gonna double a triple quadruple down on
that mission to make sure that we win
that their sacrifices weren't weren't in
vain and I think that's helping the team
understand what you're accomplishing and
why they're doing what they're doing is
is incredibly important and we wrote
about that in extreme ownership and talk
about it all the time that understanding
why briefing the team and helping them
understand why is is critical but yeah
focus on accomplishing that mission is
is what you got to do I think the other
thing too is you do everything you can
to take care of that that person and
their family take care of their family
and help them out and you know that's an
obligation that never goes away that
you're always gonna have and that's
extremely important and something that's
that's helped me through you know those
difficult losses is by serving others
and look trying to look out for others
and I got to do that even more than I do
you know another thing that can help out
in those dark times is a little bit of
jiu-jitsu to be quite frank with you
next questions about jiu-jitsu again my
BJJ coach knows it all the problem is
he's a know-it-all condescending
insulting derogatory comments to
students while classes in session
option a stay option B go to a school
down the road with less experienced but
much more mature minded teacher what
would jock will do what would life do
what would echo do I would probably move
okay
fair enough straightforward depends how
much maybe not that Street fans how much
less experience though yeah okay but but
purple about brown belt move if I'm just
beginning white belt whatever yeah move
okay late Babbitt yeah look it is a
white belt myself like I learned from
there's amazing purple belts in brown
belts out there you know I learn a ton
you know from you Abby you always show
me stuff and you you have a great knack
for teaching which is good you know
people some people just don't have that
as much and I think yeah I think that's
an if you're at the white belt level
that's that's great so I think that's
jock who apparently disagrees I know
that was a very good teacher
that is a echo you can see is you can
see him swell up a little bit a late
said it the same music impartial listen
that's cuz I've been you have taught me
things yes imagine you have a dog jackal
Dixit in that way but Wow and even if
you would yeah you should you should go
over that maybe we should do that right
now
kumite look I think you can learn from a
lot of different people and aerial down
one thing you just can't make sure you
can't make it you make sure it's your
ego getting the way and when someone's
really coaching us and now you need to
do this you need to get better and you
just don't like the manner in which
they're they're doing it publicly or
whatever you might need to put you go
and check and just say okay I don't know
everything
of course you don't let's learn if it's
over the top then yeah absolutely you
should go where you can learn best and
and the quality of the people around you
that you're rolling with this we talked
about earlier I mean that that to me is
everything and that's what I love about
jiu-jitsu is just the you know such a
diverse group of people when you get it
a great gym you're trying it and just
folks are working together and learning
together and you know they get the best
of you and then they're they're willing
to show you about how they did that or
some things you to think about keep it a
secret
it's cool my opinion on that is just
yeah I agree with you guys but at the
same time I'll say this one of the
things you got to learn to do in life is
you got to learn that you're not gonna
get along with everyone and not
everyone's personality's gonna mesh with
yours
that doesn't mean you throw away the
baby with the bathwater sure you see
what I'm saying so there might be a guy
that he's not a good teacher he treats
people like crap but he's got really
good information and he's you're
learning a lot and you so I'm gonna take
as much knowledge as I can from that
person I'm not just gonna walk away
because I don't like his attitude you
know what you're gonna have people that
you work for that have bad attitude and
you're gonna have people that work for
you that have bad attitudes you're gonna
have to learn to deal with it you're
gonna have to learn how to get as much
out of them as you can out of everybody
as a leader everybody that you got there
there's people that are gonna be good at
this but they're good at that okay well
let's let's capitalize on what they're
good at so this guy very knowledgeable
kind of a jerk let's capitalize on the
fact that he's very knowledgeable
put your ego in check and show up there
take the knowledge from him you know and
then in years to come you pay him back
pay him a visit
yeah I've uh sure in I think but overall
be there but yeah if yes if you're
getting the knowledge you're you
emphasizing your life cruising no no I
emphasize in my life getting after that
so that's there for this therefore
you're at that you're like oh this guy
doesn't cruise hard enough right right
we become I want to get anchored yeah
yeah yeah no I dig it and but I think at
the end of the day if how you said the
guy yeah he's not saying cool stuff or
he's saying stuff that's not cool or
whatever but you're still getting the
information then okay you know and also
just like with Jordan Peterson like it
pays off in life to have thick skin like
you're gonna be successful like that's
one of the ingredients for success they
dig it so if you're giving the
information for sure but a lot of times
with the know-it-all situation which is
the words he used um I've been in that
situation like a few times where it's
like I see what you're doing there and
you you be on a guy who's kind of had
some experience I'm thinking like I
don't these circumstances that you're
talking about that's not gonna work and
I know that just from experience or
whatever but this guy's to know it all
and no no I know you don't know kind of
attitude or whatever and if that
the way the whole teaching experiences
and learning quote-unquote learning
experiences I think no I think more
benefits would be gathered elsewhere
yeah it's interesting that when late
when you're talking about yeah you use
your kid as a test for yourself to calm
down and get more mature and detach and
all that that's good advice basically
doing that all the time like when I when
I meet someone that that is aroused me
the wrong way
I always look at that like okay cool I'm
gonna form a relationship with this
person become their best friend and see
if I can get through this make it happen
yeah that's maybe what I do that should
just roll yeah wall by the way I'm
taking all this knowledge from him so I
can formulate it into goodness again if
you get in the knowledge yeah good man
good but as a white belt it's like come
on bro you're gonna you you want to get
the best teaching learning overall
jiu-jitsu experience possible that's
where you know like as a new beginner
white belt or whatever I'm gonna come in
and then just get insulted by a
know-it-all or whatever like I don't
know even know if I like jiu-jitsu now
yeah kind of things and you run there or
it's not good for business that's for
sure yeah so of course hey your jock oh
I get it man
Leif gets it but we're not all chuckle
when someone says like or is a
know-it-all and I'm supposed to trust
this person to teach me you do too
because you know for all the great
reasons we take jiu-jitsu and I'm
trusting this person and they're gonna
be like how this guy explained I don't
know man I don't know a big question
mark there you go to down the street and
train yeah I would rather get 99% of the
knowledge from a good purple belt than
5% of the knowledge of a know-it-all guy
okay it's there's there's there's a
clean argument for that next question
this is from Vijay Nirmal Kumar he's
been he's been on in the game for a long
time yeah got a lot of a lot of lists
you know we've got a lot of listeners in
India
Nolen yeah actually I media from time to
time online check so he says you must
have had good days and awful ones in the
field how did you manage to stay focused
despite the ups and downs how did you
win over the darkness also what was your
workout like when you guys were engaged
in
field and probably tired two questions
there I think how you manage the ups and
downs is you got to stay focused on what
the goal is you know and I think we
talked about that how the recognition
you know when we came back from that
deployment and you put that slide
together about the Battle of her body
they kind of capture on this map you
know the the the areas that we'd taken
back and even though I plan and led
those operations you know so many of
those operations I've been intimately
involved in the planning and leading
those ops and then writing you know
post-operational summaries and all the
reports that we we had and was involved
in some of the battalion and Brigade
level meetings you know for that that
whole strategic plan I didn't really
have a fully grass just I didn't put it
all together in that way and when you
when I saw that slide that you put
together that showed you know the the
red enemy-held areas of Ramadi and all
of a sudden blue circles going in the US
bases that were put in that we were
often the lead element on the ground for
it put it all together for me in a way
that that I had not seen before it and I
recognized I had to do a better job with
my guys of doing that too and I think
that's something that for every leader
that's where that detachment comes in to
be able to think okay help me understand
what this is all about through the dark
times through the rough times so I can
focus on what the strategic goal is and
and so I can help the team understand
that as well and I think that's that's
something that you know if you step back
from the details kind of think about it
so that you can understand it and then
impart that team that to your team so
they get an understanding it enables
them to slog through when it's when it's
really difficult and it's it's dangerous
or they've got some real challenges
ahead but they can stay focused on that
that that go you also got to remember
what it feels like to do the right thing
it for me like I know what it feels like
to not do the right thing and I don't
like that feeling later right it feels
good right now to not do the right thing
because you're like oh cool bag of
Cheetos and I'm gonna get some right you
know what that feels good right there
you know what it feels like later you
know you went off the path and that's
not good so I just always think okay
well I'm gonna I'm gonna suck it up now
take the take the problem now take the
hard path now
I know later it's gonna pay off I'm
gonna feel better in the long run hey
now pay later pay now or pay later
that's stuck with me when you said it
was good yeah yeah I like when you uh
pay now and pay later
sometimes to do that sometimes me the
man now and then pay them inland and and
then hey you asked about workouts too
while we're in the field and and this is
a good one because you know like
firefighters right firefighters are on
duty for 24 hours so that means they're
gonna get a workout in at some sometimes
I do more than that but they're doing 24
hours on on duty where they're at the
station waiting for a call are you gonna
do all let's say one of the workouts
from this vehicles freedom Field Manual
are you gonna do the three sets of 20
reps squats with 20 minute rest in
between I think they call those we don't
make are you gonna do that if you if
you're if within like 15 minutes you
might be called on to carry a kid down a
ladder don't do that work out then
because you won't be ready and that's
kind of attitude in ramadi
it was like yeah we train hard certainly
and you know we talked about that on
podcast 65 of the things that carried
and and how we had to be we had to train
hard but you had to always hold a little
back cuz you never knew when you're
gonna get the call and you certainly
after a big blow hot squat workout like
that I mean you you weren't gonna be
able to run through the streets and run
up stairs and drag your 215 pound buddy
with 60 pounds of gear on you know 450
yards across the open street while
shooting with the other hand so I mean
those are the kind of things where
you've got to be ready for that and you
could you had to leave a little reserve
in the tank just in case because we got
often well we don't have an option
oh we do happen off tonight get ready oh
yes you do right on yeah so leave a
little in the tank that's a good way of
putting it okay here's a good one next
question this is for both of you did
either of you ever get into serious
trouble as a team before dream during
the military or were you always
exceptionally disciplined from a young
age
[Music]
as Rafe Beverly Pearson from you know
they're the reason I'm laughing if my if
my parents are listening to this and
they're probably laughing hysterically
right now so as our mind this is yeah I
got in all kinds of trouble all kinds of
trouble all the time I was a total wild
man I'm your brother with an arrow in
the leg or something I know he stabbed
himself okay he stabbed so we used to
shoot each other with BB guns all the
time that was and we threw Spears at
each other oh yeah you know in high
school I drove around with an old
beat-up pickup truck and I heard it from
my my uncle who'd inherited from my
grandfather and smash road signs and
just knucklehead stuff and yeah I was a
complete idiot and but you know in the
military helped score me wet certainly
and it was I'm lucky that I didn't do
something that caused me to have you
know lifelong injury or death or damage
you know I think or do something good a
bunch of trouble for for sure that would
have changes your jak2 preventing me
from going the naval camp prevented me
from going to military and and and would
have that would have redirect them up my
whole life so I I think you know you if
you're in that stage and you're a wild
teen you need to think clearly about the
long-term consequences because you
definitely can pay the man now and pay
later in that situation for sure one of
the things that we do is as young boys
I'm speaking from a boy perspective
because I'm not a girl and when I was
growing up and with the way I look back
on it now a lot of the stuff that we did
dumb stuff that we did as teenagers was
we were testing each other and we were
trying to prove ourselves that I'm tough
watch me do this like um it's almost
it's almost like if you go instinctually
as a tribe member you're proving that
you're willing to sacrifice you're
willing to take risk and sacrifice
that's what you're proving to your peers
like I'm gonna like what you just said
pickup truck I'm gonna drive down the
road and I'm gonna I'm gonna run over
this side well okay it's funny but
you're also proving to your friends that
you don't really care and can take risk
and you'll do things for the tribe
that's kind of what you're proving so I
I think again I don't want to sound like
going back to the same broken record but
if you want to get your kid or if you're
a kid and you want to prove yourself
guess what you can do you can go take
jujitsu you can learn how to fight
real you can learn how to defend
yourself you can learn how to take care
of your tribe take care of yourself take
care of your family you can do you can
learn how to beat up other people which
is an important thing I wish I would
have known it when you know you did so
you have less of a chance of getting
into a fight because the way you act is
different you don't act like a jackass
because you realize that you might get
stabbed and so you act respectful to
people and people can tell that and
you're respectful back to you so yeah
it's just another thing I think helps
out a lot
with kids because I think boys are
always trying to prove themselves to
each other and to themselves that you're
tough and that you're brave I'm trying
to prove that all you know how many
that's just this is survey how many
times did you jump off the roof of you
know buildings a lot yeah it's like why
are you doing that we actually use the
going on so we'd go fishing on the oil
rigs off the coast go deep-sea fishing
you might run 40 or 50 miles off and
you're not supposed to get on the rigs
there's all these signs and stuff but we
totally get up on the rig and just jump
off 60 feet off the top of the rig which
was awesome it was good times but we do
things to prove that we're tough but I
did a lot of dumb things when I was a
kid and most of them were to prove to to
myself and to my friends that I was
tough and then I was committed and then
I would take risks which are all that
was crazier than them which are all
positive qualities right that you want
like when we're the team's
what kind of guy what kind of teammate
you want you want a guy that's
aggressive you want a guy that will take
risks if he needs to you want a guy
that's committed that's what you want
so in these little weird tribes that we
have as teenagers that's what we have
and what are you gonna do to prove well
let's go get a fight with somebody let's
go beat someone up you know those are
all those dumb things that you do so be
smart be smart neither one of us were
model children to say say the least
alright Lafe next one lay first off
thanks for picking up the spear I'm
interested to hear more about the
Mujahideen in Ramadi how did they stack
up against US forces was it like an NFL
team playing against the high school
team or did they have tactics training
and discipline equal to our own well
first of all appreciate the thanks but
it was an honor for me to carry the
spear and as we said we'd go back there
in a heartbeat certainly
this is a great question it's a great
question I think it really gets to the
heart of what we talk about all the time
is the greatest quality in a leader and
that is humility
and when you look at the mujahideen are
the muj as we call them right the enemy
fighters who control Ramadi there were
several thousand of them by US
intelligence reports estimates when who
controlled two-thirds of the geographic
area the city when we first arrived in
the spring of 2006 with tasking a
bruiser when Jeff and I were there and
you know we were showing up our seals
are some of the best shooters in the
world there's some of the best combat
troops in the world we have highly
screened group of guys who've been
through all that the SEAL training
pipeline that's a year and a half long
probably at a minimum and and then we've
worked together for almost a year as a
seal platoon we've got guys with
extraordinary physical fitness we go to
these awesome shooting schools we train
together we have we have the best budget
and gear you know that that all the
giant Special Operations in a budget can
buy the best training and equipment and
so when we get over there we're we're
ready to go and and pound for pound if
you take you know a co operator from
Charlotte Mattoon versus one of the
moves fighters that were going up
against that co operator can do hundreds
of push-ups he can do hundreds of
bullets that's NFL's versus yes grade
school exactly and that did you know
that the moves fighter he has virtually
no training
he could probably can't do ten push-ups
he's he has none of the gear an awesome
gear that we have and and it's so it's
pound for pound that's not even
comparable and yet to think about this
from from the reality perspective right
in my platoon Charlie Patton we had 16
seals and five of those guys were
brand-new straight out of training never
been never been a combat before never
been never deployed to Iraq five of us
and we're going up against the enemy
that has had three years at that time
three straight years of non-stop
real-world combat experience and so the
the experience level is not even
comparable when we're going up against
these guys they know the city they I
mean and they're able to use our
weaknesses against us
whereas we got to carry all the heavy
weight and you know the body armor the
helmets and
and we're not acclimatized to 115 or
hundred you know 20 degree high during
the during the day in the heat of the
summertime they are and they live there
and they don't have to carry water arm
and they don't have to carry body armor
in helmets and they they they can just
throw a backpack with seven RPG rockets
in a rocket tube and roll out with their
flip-flops and knock off Adidas
tracksuit which is what they generally
wore and and you know are there belt-fed
no Russian machine gun said they used
they weren't near as good as the ones we
had but they were they were deadly and
they could use them and they could shoot
and and so you could never ever ever
take those guys for granted and I think
that's the if they would always be
looking to probe weaknesses and they
weren't there to fight us head-to-head
they would try to take advantage of our
weaknesses they were very good at
analyzing a situation looking at a
weakness and taking advantage of that
weakness of probing for him and and if
you ever took them for granted I mean
they were good they were gonna there you
were sent yourself they might hit you
hard anyway and you might get got to
lose guys even if you were prepared but
if you weren't prepared and he started
taking for that M for granted you start
of getting complacent and not respecting
them as an enemy then then you were
gonna fail and they kind of I mean for a
lack of a better word they they cheat -
that's the thing right so you guys have
rules of engagement all this stuff and
they just straight up and and what's I
would say even more important that is
they don't have value for human life
than value their own lives they're
they're literally suicide bombers and so
that you know they could lose five they
even want to die yeah they wanted they
want to achieve martyrdom in many cases
and so you know them dying is is not a
huge impact and then obviously for for
Americans and American soldiers and our
friends it's it's it's epic and and
crushing loss of life every single time
and so that is the the biggest
difference is that we have to it's like
being it's like you know he says if this
is what he says he says it's his NFL
versus high school team right well the
the if the NFL should destroy that team
right completely destroy it
but if the high-school team scores a
single point they kick a field goal yeah
they get lucky and kick a field goal
that's that's a win and that's that's
courage that's crushing and that's kind
of what it's like they're not gonna win
they're not gonna win the game but even
when they put a score on the board man
it's crushing and one thing that you
know as I think about it too that the
what was unique about that task unit
bruiser diploma to her mind in 2006 was
deployed three times to Iraq I had quite
a you know Jaco made multiple
deployments to Iraq we a lot of you know
we had a handful guys have been there
multiple times and guys that went later
Afghanistan and and elsewhere around the
world and saw significant combat
operations but what was unique about
that was we were we were going on foot
do you want to drive cuz you get blown
up with his you know horrific IDs we're
gonna destroy your vehicles so we park
our vehicles we had to carry everything
on her backs and and and walk into deep
deep into enemy territory in places
where we knew that it was very unlikely
that that tanks could even get to us to
help us out in some cases and if they
did if they we're gonna try to come in
they might very well get blown up and
kill so what was interesting about that
is you know we might have eight or ten
or you know seal sometimes it maybe it
was 20 seals but but that's a fairly
small group you know we've had some
Iraqi soldiers with us but we didn't
count them when it came to they didn't
count when it came to I hate who's gonna
actually be able to defend this position
but I had to have the expectation that
that we might very well have 5060 enemy
fighters surrounding our position attack
us and they could easily overrun us and
what was unique about that the point was
we didn't have dedicated air support we
didn't have a dedicated quick reaction
force that was gonna come out and help
us that only was supporting us unlike
you know some other civil combat
operations that have happened elsewhere
and it was or on other deployments that
I was on and we were on our own we had a
plan for that and and you had to
recognize that they could they would
absolutely bring it and they would try
to kill you overrun your position and
kill everybody capture someone and that
was a real possibility that we had to be
we had to recognize could happen at any
time and we had to be ready for it well
just to just state a statement of fact
on top of what you're saying the
enemy did the enemy did overrun friendly
positions multiple times while we're
there and killed dozens of people and
some of those you know some of those
heavily fortified ECP's would get
completely over attacked to overrun
vehicle-borne ID so yeah it wasn't like
this could happen that this is actually
happening well while we were there
friendly positions got overrun by the
enemy and so yeah it was not just it
could happen but it is happening and
it's a it's a it could happen to us
tonight tomorrow night whatever yet they
were good they used a cover move they
lay down fire support each other they
they they buy together Atlanta get and
combine our mission they've combined
arms you know they'd come in with the
the machine gunfire and then the RPG
fire and the mortar fire and and then
all of a sudden there'd be a vbid that's
that's what they do and there were
different levels within there as well I
mean sometimes you get shot at and it
was kind of a spray and praise someone
dump it on a K in your direction and
then other times you'd have multiple
belt-fed machine guns hitting you that
were you know coming through a little
you know 3 or 3 by 4 foot window from a
hundred yards away and they're coming
inches over your head and you're looking
at each other like man these guys know
what they're doing
they they say you could tell when you
know the guys who've been there for a
while maybe come from elsewhere they
brought it and you could never take that
program and also luckily for us even
though we might not have a dedicated QRF
we had the best damn QRF in the world
which was absolutely the one one ad and
they were awesome and never failed to
come and and save any asses of T you
they brave those roads over and over and
over and over again jumping in their
tanks taking such tremendous risk or
driving it home these down these
horribly dangerous roads we didn't want
to drive to come help us out and they do
that all the time they were they were
awesome and we couldn't done any of our
operations without without them next
question and that's actually a good
question it's it's how did the Naval
Academy prepare you to lead and actually
a lot of a lot of listeners at the Naval
Academy and a lot of listeners at West
Point I hear from them and actually I
got sent necessary the helmet I got sent
somebody sent me a hand-painted Navy
football helmet pretty awesome with a
warship on it
yeah I'll show it to you Sapp here it's
awesome
thanks for sending me that by the way
it's awesome so like like I said a lot
of listeners we've had Brian stand on
you know he talked about his experiences
there and a lot of leadership he got
from the Naval Academy was actually from
playing football when you listen to him
he's playing football the Naval Academy
which was was a challenge for him but he
learned a lot of leadership lessons
there how did the Naval Academy prepare
you to lead well first of all I love my
spirit in the Naval Academy and for me
that was all about the the people that I
I served with you know and the folks
that I met and and the things that we
went through together I got in a lot of
trouble Naval Academy I struggled my
grades something we talked about
previously I got I had a big conduct
record because I still did some of those
knucklehead teenage things and rebelled
against Authority but frankly you know
look there's great people there you know
there's great people on the staff I've
got a very close friend there's a
battalion officer now and it's awesome
to have good people there that are
passing lessons on to you know to those
young midshipman is as they graduated
for and for every academy or artiste you
know for that matter I saw you know
because you have such a wide swath of
officers from all different you know
from all different you know Navy Marine
Corps I mean every kind of different
branch of within those services as well
and and also you have a midshipman
leadership hierarchy right you've got
someone who because they made good
grades or had a good conner ever got got
promoted into this kind of make believe
you see that right there yeah a little
bit a little bit of you know a little
bit of anger about that one right there
just cuz they got good grades you know
they really love breakfast
they're gonna be in charge of me listen
there were some resentful this is a new
wave I just met a new life resentful
life I'm actually not at all resentful I
uh I can tell you I had some I had some
good friends who were in those positions
and it was great for them you know
good for them it's it's kind of it's
just it's funny looking back now because
it's completely meaningless right when
you're do you have a regimental
commander there yeah
is that guy in charge of all the
students yeah there's there's but you
know there's regiment brigade and
battalion dados yes they have it to that
when I was at OCS I was the man
I'll do the regimental in red calm so no
wonder the sense of this red calm
confident huh
are they also called the five bar
because he the only person with fire
bars on your little uniform did they
call you captain big-time no they come
real president day I was a president of
my class too
I had a good time though yes so so now
now we see the sensitivity there yeah
listen I you know great we maybe you
should have studied or bad like I made
some kids now or I hear from I get I get
correspondence from people at the Naval
Academy and like I can see that they're
in the game I can see that they're like
all this is going on and I'm gonna get
I'm gonna like you know I'm saying like
you think you could have been you could
have had that no question about yeah
yeah no would it have mattered at the
time I don't know you know failure as we
say is often the best teacher look I
made I made great grades in high school
and did well on my SATs and a CTS
without with almost no study I got super
it I didn't have the discipline that was
in place once I got to the Naval came in
that structure it was it was difficult
for me it was very hard for me as I went
in to assist an engineering program and
and those sort of they saw so I struggle
with that so that could have helped me
if somebody had if I'd have learned this
one equals freedom at a young age and
recognized the power in that I'd be way
way more ahead you know in life wouldn't
we all for sure what about playing the
game yeah and playing the game as well
right that I'm gonna buck authority of
let you know what actually it's gonna be
a lot worse for you if you just you know
even from a just personal perspective
not only works for you but you're free
your squad or for your you know these
folks that you care about if you just
build a better relationship with the
folks above you instead of being the you
know hard-headed argumentative guy for
sure it was way better friend I I don't
know when I figured that out I mean it
was definitely it was definitely in my
enlisted time I started figuring out
that oh I'm working for a guy but and I
can either make my life I can either
tell him he sucks and in my life is
gonna suck out or I can figure out how
to work with him and that's gonna make
my life better and by the way it's just
I'm just gonna make my life better it's
gonna make us do a better job as a team
so it's interesting when you pick up on
that in life and obviously if I would
have been going to the Naval Academy at
18 you know I was a knucklehead you know
I would have been in the same boat of
like oh I'm gonna stick it to the man
right I mean I'm still listening it's a
tenacious d at age whatever and we're
still sticking it to the man
well I'll tell you the people that I
really like like my upperclassmen I
really like we have some there you know
still serving the SEAL Teams and and a
great guys that help influence me and
and I expected when I showed up there I
wanted to be a seal yeah I wanted to go
to war that's what I wanted to do and it
was very hard for me to recognize there
like not everybody wanted to do that it
was exactly like me it was so it was you
know that some people were a little more
academic I wanted to be on the
intelligence side I wanted to be you
know that they wanted to drive a ship or
they wanted to be on a submarine or that
you know they those things that you know
will fly a plane I'm a Top Gun and come
as a bit you know we had a whole bunch
of Pele that wanted to be you know
pilots they'd gone to school so it was
it was interesting people were a lot
different than I expected and and some
folks didn't quite have the the warlike
mentality that that I expected everyone
might have you know going into that
environment but there's no question that
if I had done a better job of you know
you call it playing playing the game
just seeing that you know detaching and
seeing like hey listen thinking
strategically thinking strategic if we
want to see if we well I don't want to
say play the game because that sounds -
yeah - usually I want to build relations
what DB that is near to devious we're
not I didn't recognize that it was not
in my benefit or the benefit the people
around me to to create antagonistic
relationships and that so rather than
de-escalate those situations I rebelled
against them and pushed against them and
it was a struggle for me yeah and it
took me a long time to figure that out
now that being said though there you
know there's it the naval caves no
different than anywhere else there was a
great leaders there who mentor people
and train people and represented you
know folks well that were both officers
on the staff and I listened on the staff
as well as you know is midshipman so but
I think what what was a lesson for me
and looking back on it now that I
recognized it's great to identify who
you don't want to be and if someone does
something that's looking out for
themselves or throws people under the
bus or you know those those leaders that
you start losing respect for it's great
to actually identify that and and that's
a good lesson to learn to say okay good
I want to make sure I don't be that that
way but what what I have learned is that
I can't be we talk to leaders about this
all the time and I keep it what do you
do you know your boss they're just using
a good
you're like guess what the SEAL Teams is
one of the most highly screened
organizations in the world what's uh
what's the percentage of senior leaders
that I work for that I had respect for
that go and work for again you know
that's maybe maybe 20% maybe 20% of the
people I work for were during my time
and guess that's about average as you
talk to people you know it's about
average in the business world's better
it's certainly the naval cab any of
those places so if you're expecting that
there's good most of the world out there
it's not gonna be a good leader they're
not gonna be later and that doesn't
matter and that shouldn't affect your
performance you should be able to do you
know something that I learned from you
which has probably been the most helpful
thing that you ever taught me was then I
should try to have the same relationship
with with every boss you know whether I
had deep respect and admiration for them
or whether I despised them and thought
they were you know egomaniac who you
know are a coward who you know couldn't
mitigate risk so and that it's in my
benefit in my teens benefit to build
that relationship with with my team and
that was that was a lesson that I had
not learned then so yeah those negative
those negative lessons learned were good
for me and also I would have had less
negative lessons learned if I don't
figure this out earlier
yeah same and really we got time for
like one more question but it's almost
the same vein so I think it's a good
question to ask it says life at what
point did you become enlightened to
extreme ownership and how did you
respond to the philosophy kind of same
vein of what you were just talking about
exactly I mean I I clearly didn't have
that fully at the Naval Academy but I
started to understand through the kind
of school of hard knocks and fall on my
face and getting too much of trouble
realizing hey doesn't benefit me to
rebel against Authority or you know not
do it I'm told or be seen as you know as
someone who's you know doesn't respect
the rules or whatever and and I think I
started to learn that a little more in
the service fleet because I my goal I
went out served it was crushing to me to
not be selected out of Naval Academy and
to go into the SEAL program so as I went
out and served on a couple different
surface ships I recognized like the what
is the pathway from me did to the SEAL
Teams but my lifelong dream that's all I
want to do and it was be the
frickin surface warfare now you gotta
just so everyone knows now you got to
earn a recommendation to go and do this
so if you're not the best fleet officer
you could possibly be someone's gonna go
why would you why would you send you the
SEAL Teams and you you're not even doing
a good job here no so you got to earn a
reputation you'll also have to in a
recommendation for sure you so you have
to build that trust with your bosses and
you have to get qualified so they've got
to trust you and you have to achieve
that qualification you're not even
eligible until your warfare
qualification so in Sony when you report
about aboard a ship you have to do
certain qualifications that say okay yes
you are now a Surface Warfare Officer a
qualified Surface Warfare Officer
there's a bunch of boxes you got a check
and it boxes you got to learn all kinds
of information about all the the
hundreds of different systems and until
you get that you're not even gonna get
you you're not getting a recognition
Ellis do you get that you're not even
eligible you're not eligible so you had
to just you had to get so and that
helped me and I still had friction
certainly and and but I started
recognizing like what works and what
doesn't and but it wasn't really until
tasking a bruiser that that's where you
really quantify that for me and you know
as we were going through I was in my
second ball too so I'd already been
through a previous platoon and and and I
read I didn't even realize like as in
that second but the the second platoon
is we were working at asking a bruiser
with Charlie Patton was like man we're
good
we're performing well and when we
started having you know a few months
into the workup cycle we'd have you know
training instructors be like you guys
are the best tasking we've ever seen
come through here and it was interesting
to me because I was like well I don't
really I mean we have some amazing guys
in this task unit but I had an amazing
guys my last task unit too we had very
challenged so it's not really the talent
factor that broke us out you know and
and I I didn't even realize it he
certainly wasn't that we didn't make
mistakes cuz we made all kinds of
mistakes and task unit bruiser and you
know disastrous training operations
where we had to come back and revamp our
training process and and make sure that
we dialed in standard operating
procedures just what trainees exactly
and right exactly that's the difference
really yeah and that was it it was it
was this idea that we now call extreme
ownership which is we're gonna take
ownership of this and instead of being
like hey we're gonna push back against
people that are tell us we need to be
better or we're gonna eat maybe even
deny it
we're as bad as we are we're gonna take
a brutally honest assessment of
ourselves and that that's one thing that
really stands out to me as I think about
it do you remember our debriefs
that the training instructors there
usually have a super lengthy and
critical debrief we would debrief
ourselves after a run cuz they let that
let double turns and the tasking to go
first and so often it was the only time
I ever saw it to help my you know my 9
years in the SEAL Teams that that most
of the time we would get done debriefing
ourselves and and the training
instructors did not have they had either
nothing to say or maybe just a couple
sentences and that was it yeah because
we'd ripped ourselves to shreds because
we were that was such a brutally honest
assessment of and sometimes they'd be
like hey I actually thought you guys did
pretty good
shut up we're yeah we're working and
that's actually you told you told them
right yeah to say the worst see you
don't ever tell my guys that they're
doing you know they're they're amazing
that's the best run they've ever seen
because that bet that allows us to not
get better to not grow to get complacent
so we always did that and I think that's
I I was starting to I recognize just how
powerful that was to our performance so
again we were never flawless we always
made we made mistakes but we learn from
those mistakes we got better
we grew all the time and we were able to
run circles around everybody else as a
result and deliver some exceptional
performance on the battlefield with that
attitude and that's that that mindset an
attitude is is the game changer that's
why we called the book extreme ownership
and it's what we impart to people as we
we see in the business world and it
there's at the end of it is what works
and there's what doesn't work
but that tasking a bruiser and working
with you and recognizing what that is
and how powerful that is that's that's
made all the difference it's crazy to
see and I'd see this all the time that
well you just think about what you're
saying it when that when the training
cadre for instance tells you hey it took
you guys a long time to get a head count
meaning you're on the target and you
want to leave the target before you
leave the target you've got to know that
you've got all your people so you want
to get a head count so the training
contract says hey it took you guys a
long time to get a head count now you
can do one of two things here you can
say okay that's conscripted sysm how
could we get a faster headcount hey guys
anyone ever done this a different way
I have used this process in the past it
works really good okay let's try that oh
that worked better and we do this one
little thing it can be even a little bit
faster okay let's rehearse it let's
actually try and rehearse it okay boom
now we're getting really good so so we
take that and all of a sudden the next
time we go out we do a little bit better
and then we've modified a little bit
more and all of a sudden we can get a
head count in 15 seconds instead of 4
minutes which is a huge difference when
you're trying to leave a target so
that's one attitude AB that's like we're
gonna take ownership of the problems but
I would see this all the time which is
hey guys your your head count was a
little slow and guys gap wasn't that bad
wasn't that bad and only took us 4
minutes 4 minutes is not that big of a
deal like or like do that guys saying
that right now but I'd like to see him
get a head count faster than that and we
did it as fast as we could do it
everyone counted as faster we could and
we made it through the first time that
took us three minutes and they're gonna
say that's not good enough
hey don't worry about that and so you're
gonna stay on that pattern and you never
get better and you're never gonna get
better and it's because you're not
looking you're not accepting criticism
from the outside and it's like when we
see that with leaders now III started
without Dave and I were just working
with it with it with a team and and we
had to say it comes up all the time and
and it's funny when you see people
pushing back against some some real
constructive criticism and my question
is I was like okay I said I just you
know that battle of egos there I look at
that and say okay what you're telling
just just let me understand you're
telling me that you
you are an absolute optimal performance
you can never improve in any way is that
is that is that what you're saying and
obviously then they read on as like of
course not so so that kind of opens the
door of yeah you can improve and you
should improve and if you're not what
you taught me is not only should you
improve I think the big lesson that I
learned from you and that we now you
know teach here with us on fairness is
that if not only should you improve but
if you're not trying to do better if
you're not doing everything you can to
have the most efficient and effective
headcount that you can and improve in
every aspect of your game all the time
that you're actually failing your as a
leader and you're failing your team and
I think that's a very fundamental
difference of looking at it yeah that
it's not just no I should be doing that
but no if I'm not doing that I'm a
failure as a leader and I'm failing
yeah and all this is weird you know
talking about this headcount thing it's
it's a great example about it very much
because it's a it's a really big deal
like for instance when you leave a
target you can't leave until you know
that you have all your guys so you got
to get a headcount there's multiple
different ways to get a headcount
and the easiest way is you use
decentralized command and every little
team leader counts their three or four
guys they go yeah ones up two up threes
up and they report in up one level and
by the time I would need a headcount I'd
look at life and and the Delta poon
commander I'd be like hey are we up and
it would take them 10 seconds to pick
one up the the way the worst way to do
it which I would also see would be you
would literally count from from the
lowest guy there's 36 guys in the troop
and someone would say hey head count and
the back guy would go 36 35 and they
would you'd have assigned numbers 35 34
33 32
hey who's 31 31
Oh over here sir wait you're 31
no I'm 32 well did you count and see
that Union it takes three minutes four
minutes and and yet it's like well that
that's a very sensible way on paper to
do it because you know you're gonna have
all your people but in reality it
doesn't work and that's that one and so
this is that one little thing right this
one little thing a little improvement
you can make but but that's not the only
improvement you can make you can improve
every little thing that you do and every
little thing that you do is a team
everything that you do has a individual
human being you could make it just a
little bit better and the minute that
you're you're you're sitting back in
your year you're going you know what I'm
not gonna make this change anymore
I'm I've reached my pinnacle of
performance in this category the minute
that you do that is not just one
category that you're slacking off on
it's all of them and I was telling you
guys the other day I'm like you know
when you see me post a picture in the
morning that is saying to god I'm
getting up but I'm knocking it before 30
if he says to 4:35 that means I got up
at 4:30 and I got out of bed and I went
in it and and and I took a picture my
watch and I post it when I'm posting it
at 4:08 that means I woke up and I was
like I gotta get busy he's like it's not
all on it's not a lot of clock I'm gotta
get I gotta go do I gotta go make these
things happen I got a look in
see where I can improve my method for
getting a head count how can I make it
that much faster that one little thing
and when you look at your array of what
you're going on in your business and
it's also in your life - what can you do
a little bit better you attack those
problems you accept the criticism when
it comes at you which is so hard for
everyone to do myself included you
accept the christen you listen to it and
then you modify and you make these
little iterative changes and at the end
instead of being a decent task unit or
instead of being a decent person or
instead of running a decent team you can
be the best and that's only happens if
you take ownership of what's going on in
your world with that echo Charles yes
speaking of taking ownership trying to
get better yes maybe you could help us
out with that a little bit I don't know
yes blossom that's interesting though
like where it when you put into
perspective the extreme ownership
because you know you say the biggest or
one of the the biggest best qualities of
a leader is humility humility yeah Ryan
right now right
more so you know yes because you figure
okay so yeah stripe brother stripe on
the on the leadership white belts there
you go so you you get a 10 you know a
team of people all different you know
personalities whatever Eagles different
varying levels right so for little
there's gonna be all these little
problems no one's perfect no one's
optimal right that's kind of the goal
even if it's unattainable perfection
right that's the kind of the gold
optimal then you have a team with
however many mistakes they make and then
as they train perform all this stuff all
the little mistakes get pointed out and
it's almost like this self
self-correcting organism we hope it is
like that's why yes you hope it is so
like if you compare it to like a machine
learning situation it does that cuz
doesn't have an ego it doesn't take
things personal it's kind of like let me
just solve all the little problems and
then that's why they can what grow and
exponential rates right the thing that's
awesome about that though is that you
get what I think what your time I was
building the culture right so you get if
the leaders doing that and you get two
team doing that once once people
recognize like hey
look how much better we art headcounts
yeah even if I resisted that then you
start getting junior leadership who knew
you know frontline troops knew guys who
you know they come up with an idea I
usually we can this'll better solving
provinces you don't even see yeah it's a
saying that the other day
you know I was I was in a training
situation the other day and I saw things
go bad for this group there's a military
group and and things were going bad they
were they they all drop the ball they
all kind of didn't drop the ball but
they're slack there they were slack and
I was thinking to myself I wouldn't see
a young new guy machine gunner not get
in a good position I would never see
that with my eyes because the guy that
was immediately senior to him would
would straighten him out hmm there would
be no slack right there there'd be no
psych you get straight now so by the
time I show up and I look around
everyone's doing amazingly well
everything's the way it should be it's
not quite optimal but it's damn close
and why is that it's because what you
just said leh if it's because every
leader every individual leader and every
person is adjusting and making things
making adjustments and I'm not even
seeing and why are they doing that
number one because they're all humble
enough to look that they need to change
things and number two everyone in the
group has their ego in check so when
someone says hey shift your field to
fire a little bit to the west the guy
doesn't say why yeah no he goes I wonder
why oh I see cuz he's got another guy
over there that's covering that field if
I got it yeah got it boss yeah that's
that's what that's it now we have like
like a machine that's just improving all
the time yeah which is what we're going
for
and if you lack humility in any in any
one of those levels you're you're gonna
slow down that machine's progress that
process fully duh yeah so it's weird
when you look at it from the big picture
you know and you see like just like are
you saying when you kind of mentally
compared your current team with you know
teams in the past like oh there was
talented guys on the other side on the
other teams that I was on too but you
kind of understand and recognize that
one factor is that everyone's kind of
humbling is always constantly like what
can I do better right here with my you
know situation in my own little world
here but everyone's doing that so it's
like this if you if you kind of
collectively consider this group there
boom-boom-boom self sylph and i'll take
it one step forward just just one step
further just so everyone can think about
how to implement this in your world the
way you implement it isn't by saying
guys the head count will slow you need
to fix it
it's not by saying hey the approach the
target was too loud you need to be quiet
that's not how you fix the problem you
say hey guys our head count is taking
too long
I need to come up with a better way to
do it I need to I need I need to figure
this out or hey guys we were too noisy
going to the target I need to make sure
that you have the gear that you need and
I need to make sure we all understand
how important it is to be quiet going to
the target mm-hmm I think I was too loud
right I think I was mm everyone says
Pam's like he's blaming himself for
being too loud but I'm the one that was
over back there my dropped my canteen it
made a bunch of noise in the rocks that
was my fault I'm gonna take myself up
yeah as opposed to blaming everyone and
we talked about this all the time
the minute you're blaming everyone
everyone's just you know they're looking
for excuse they're blaming you you don't
understand how hard it is to carry that
canteen quietly and I was thirsty cuz
I've been carrying the machine gun and I
need to get water right there I was
gonna get dehydrated there's makin
excuses yeah and the machine can't self
correct the machine can't self can't do
it just stays in the one inefficient
ineffective place mode speaking of
machines machines need oil not
necessarily krill oil but we need krill
oil B plus chocalate supplements good
news I almost took my Jacko krill oil
this morning don't forget can't slack on
that thanks for bringing me some krill
oil in New York too by the way
yeah that you still owe me a bottle for
them yeah no problem I know a guy and
the krill oil is called Jocko super
krill and joint warfare by the way which
is another joint supplement you know
maintain the physical capabilities of
your body um I said don't forget to take
it and don't run out by the way I ran
out before but if you're running out
there is a subscription option by
request by request yeah you get it what
every month
you can get it every month every two
weeks this was this was cool though
because the indicator was when people
order krill oil during warfare guess
what they do they order more yeah and
then they order more and so then the
requests were can we just put it on
subscription so there uh I mean I don't
I just take three of them three of each
boom but I'd never read like how much
should I be taking this a little bit
more like strong right like this or I'll
tell you what I take I take three of
each in the morning and I take three at
night so yeah that's good and that's
fine but what is the recommended you're
also talking to guy that you know who
orders the forty out steak to be good
better yeah I would say I would say it
depending on your weight but I'd say
like two and two take two of each in the
morning to each at night and also you
can pour it in okay yeah you can also do
this you can also you know see where
you're at right like you know what it
feels like when you haven't been taking
your like yeah so then up the dose
that's right have not been real real
confident with where I'm at yeah me too
three and three for me not twice it one
one time three and three boom morning I
gotta get my subscription though that's
good I like that option cuz I run out
and and then and then it takes later
yeah you that's what sucks is it takes
like three days right three days you're
like oh my oh I haven't been taking it
and then you got to get back on it and
it takes another couple days it's whack
yeah get some subscription if you're
into it
well why'd he get that anyways oh well
there's more stuff what yeah yeah if you
want to go get it right now or gin
mancom that's where you get it also at
origin mancom also Jocko supplement it's
called discipline it's a three mission
cognitive enhancers micro dose of
caffeine if you're into it just like
chocolate tea the bottle just sample so
fast yeah see tasty which is I mean yeah
I mean right again I know I said it
before but it doesn't seem like you're
all like focused on taste cuz you're not
focused on looks no seem sane not at all
yeah but you like this
yeah yeah and make sure stuff tastes
good apparently but it is good stuff
I take that one every day too when do
you take it morning
now pre pre daily life free day Manulife
you know why the way I see it is like
there's no caffeine or there's not like
huge amounts of caffeine so it's like
okay if I'm gonna micro dose
yeah I ripped that off from Tim Ferriss
what my crew does they talk about micro
dosing LSD and micro dose psycho drugs
whatever sounds cool that's not really
my thing
I'll take a little micro dose of
caffeine yeah a few milligrams sure but
give you a little glimpse in Meerut
world I don't think you to do it well
the LSD might yes for sure oh yes get
some of that sometimes I just figured
they'd like the cognitive and here
enhancing nutrients I figure that's like
a thing that's not like a drug right
this nutrient so let's see take it every
day so your brain is just generally more
capable it's just what I figured all
right he's answered all these good
questions they got the discipline or
maybe the the neurons are firing I've
been on it vessel that's why I got those
stripes yeah 19% increase in performance
thanks by the way also anyway um you
know Matt or Jemaine calm also at origin
main dot-com is where you get your key
straight up you have or Jinky I do have
an orange key in there they're awesome
I have comments on all the time they're
they're great geese they're super
lightweight but they're super strong and
yeah definitely my favorite duty yeah
I'm looking to get another one
mine too and made in America by the way
Bryan emailed me yesterday you might
think that's the best thing about origin
geese that isn't made in America but
then it's not because you get the game
you realize that yeah it's awesome
yeah because if it was made in America
and then you're like cluster homemakers
only the other night I was rolling in
the Deaf key the interesting thing we
obviously we know I'm not a fashion guy
right well I mean clearly I'm not a
fashion
we could leave can tell you want say
your stories you can tell life tell
stories about my fashion 1987 tape of
jeans and Danner combat boots
hey that's how I roll but when you put
on the Deaf key everyone says something
yeah why is that it's just cuz it look
Ellen because it's not flashy
it just says this money was freedom and
then it says get out on the back that's
not every time I walk by people when I'd
walk by the night here I'm going to get
after it like you know what is like that
though what has like an element of
fashion in his stuff no I know I got to
put him in check on that a little bit
like hey you got to put that in check
yeah you want it because he made some he
made some spats oh yes but which is an
approved term now yes Lafe compression
pants compression bits tights is what
serious abandoned Gollum Spanish but
anyways he made something that work is
that like jeggings no way too far
they're jeans but they're late it's I
know this because my daughter has some
and it's like what teenagers you know
jeggings are kebab they're like legging
/ geez well yeah Pete has more fashion
sense because he's got that whole design
thing going on yeah like he's a designer
yeah yeah it's a creative I know you
listening Pete no you're all designing
stuff up there me I'm like make it black
yeah yeah what can we add to it more
black and what kind of shape do you want
in the waistline I don't know about that
kind stuff but Pete's like I don't worry
I got it yeah and that's why until he
designed the multicolored spats wow
that's just like just taken together I
can't even I can't even
I'm not even put myself in check here
because I realize that that is beyond my
domain of competency right there that is
way beyond my domain of competency so if
you want to get those spats yeah go for
it
seeing it but to Pete's credit guess
what they have now
black black spats there you go if you
need them you could get them boom but
even his even the other G's though
people before I got the Deaf one people
would be like oh that's a nice deal
what's really interesting is when you
see the we've-- yeah we've-- is what
makes it guerilla we yeah but there's
like this little pattern in the dragon
eye
the first one of the first ones I
actually held was yours life could
you've had an origin key for a long time
yeah because you asked me a long time
ago before I was even with origin you're
like hey what kind of Gish I said get a
damn origin game ass I'm coming you tell
me about it and uh you know they went
and got one ball was good and I was like
damn this thing is nice but yeah there's
no pattern all right cool yeah we get it
sorry what I'm just saying crazy you
don't care about the pageant people
sneak it in there just for like the rush
to come out of fashion or gonna watch
out for Pete subtle fashion it's good
keep it upbeat I think also some rash
guards they're all made in America and
some other stuff check it out if you
like something get something or Jin main
comm is the website also on it calm
slash Chuck okay on it this is where I
get my kettlebells kettlebells your
ghetto bows yeah so that the whole set
primal bells all that stuff also maces
and other workout stuff if you wanna you
want to switch it up you don't do a
boring workout anymore or you're bored
with your workouts switch it up on it
calms let's check out the workout it's
good get something also when you buy
extreme ownership way to worry kid or
any of the books Jocko may or may not
review on this podcast um don't worry I
organized all those books I made it
shirt too by the way whole no story I'll
go into that later but I organized all
the books by episode by the way get them
through there good way to support it'll
take you to Amazon get your book get
whatever else you're getting and you
know carry on lawnmower
notice that lately a lot of lawn mowers
people buying lawn mowers it ready for
spring yeah through the amazon click
through yeah I think it's in there to
support can you buy a driving lot more
because when I think lawn more I think
Amazon you probably can probably hear
John here yeah I like this I bought a
leaf blower and I'm not joking there you
go
my daughter please it recharge it once
can you get an 84 millimeter recoilless
rifle carl gustaf no I don't think so no
no that is the damn [__] one of my
buddies was asking me that the day he
was gonna go shooting and and he's a
he's a British guy and his name is
English pizza and sure an English pizza
hero industries
they call them English pitas his
nickname English Pizza PE tah English
Pizza an English Pizza was gonna go
shooting with someone and he says hey
you don't want to go he says hey I'm
gonna go shoot tink would you like to
come maybe we could work on some cover
and move and I was like I was like I was
like I can't make it and then I saw him
later and I said oh how was the shooting
he said halogen gets go mate could go
and I said oh that's a bummer I said
you're gonna like it he goes I really
want to shoot is like the RPG stuff but
if they do hey whatever you know when
you buy your book buy one of those cool
also subscribe to the podcast if you
have it already stitcher iTunes Google
Play
Spotify mm-hmm you know Spotify I do you
know what there's a bunch of other
podcast apps and I don't even know what
their names are you start tweeting the
the locations of those I gotta figure
them all out yeah well there's a bunch
yeah and they're coming out with new
ones
yeah like this just you'd think we kind
of said before you'd think Oh iTunes
right that's where podcasts are but
podcast is a podcast
yeah what's interesting and I've seen
this factually or I don't know where the
number came from so like two years ago
18% of America was listening to podcasts
18:18 like when we started that's the
number I got I was like researching oh
how many people are listening to it
right now so it's been two years 48% of
Americans listen to podcasts and that
right there is explosive growth it's
pretty amazing because it's a great
medium yeah yeah it's like kind of like
having a conversation on the podcast but
yeah I agree fully so yeah subscribe if
you want good way to support also
YouTube subscribe to youtube if you want
if you're interested in the video
version of this podcast where ever guess
life Bevan the guest episodes that's
when people watch them typically mostly
mostly yeah well I don't want yet not
even really mostly I'm just saying we
see more people watching the episodes
with with guests I wanna see what they
look like a parody oh yeah unless if
you're interested in that
and excerpts if you don't want to
necessarily watch the whole podcast you
can watch just like little clips of it
or whatever you want sharing with your
friends whatever we provide that as well
also enhanced excerpts that's what we're
calling them them some of that too
anyway various video types on there and
you and you I've seen you've been a
little bit more year so you're throwing
more punches now more yeah we're gonna
keep that going so yeah there'll be more
clips to choose from you know you don't
listen or watch whatever yeah so yeah
subscribe good way to support also
chocolate store it's called choco store
of course chocolate store calm that's
where you can get discipline equals
freedom shirts victory MMA shirts
someone chocolate wears every day while
we do the podcast and otherwise and you
don't get out in any way this shirts on
those podcasters jaco gear shirts also
rash guards also hoodies also hats did
you mention a new shirt is there a new
shirt I mentioned you sure is it out
because I haven't approved or seen
anything now yeah yeah it's in limbo
right now but I I'm very we're confident
it's like the patches you see really
wants you to do it openly I think you'll
approve cuz there's no colored shirts
okay good yeah approved and then you
know actually is called back to the book
oh no surprise before said before but I
think it's coming along with a few
layers on there and you know I'm gonna
go ahead and offer it oh yeah you can't
release it until there's enough layers
yes no yeah layer list shirts are on a
prove who is the most I the shirt that I
designed is the most layered shirt is
that correct yes I think is that you
submitted quite easily there yeah it's
true the truth you have the woody call
it the gift of truth or what it was it I
don't know you know when when they're
like hey what if the our competition is
gossiping about us you have the oh yeah
I have the big weapon yeah the Webster
the true the high ground yeah so you got
numbers on your site nonetheless
chocolate or calm nice we can get all
the cool stuff check it out if you want
something get something also
psychological warfare if you don't know
what that is it's an album with tracks
choco tracks
when you run into those moments of
weakness in your campaign against
weakness
speaking of which so I'm getting my car
you know I've got thousands of songs on
my iTunes oh yeah I get I get in my car
you know how did I have my bluetooth on
you realize it but it just automatically
synced up my trucks I I jump in my truck
and and I didn't realize the radio was a
kind of a highball apparently I think my
kids were ice cream in the backseat so
I'll play like some kid kids but I get
in there I get in there and and all of a
sudden it's like Jacko's voice hey I get
it I'm done to pay attention backing up
and it's like it's kind of where it does
discipline and of all the random you
know thousands of songs that I have on
my iTunes like that comes up I was like
what are the odds and it was actually
something I needed to hear at that
moment and and to remind me to get back
on the path so there you go that is
something that's extremely helpful
perfect and the the universe the
universe aligns versatile Charles for
that anybody because echo Charles
originally said to me like hey what do
you do here and I answered him some
question it was it was like my skill
work yeah what are you is like oh how do
you not skip workouts and I was like I
bump up a ba he's like bro we need to
record that and put it out so people can
listen to it he's like and you should
answer the rest of you should go what
what how do you get out of bed stars in
Samarra asked me the questions and
that's where it came from that controls
yeah a little additional thing you know
how the kind I don't know if you've run
into this where you're like I'm confused
or I don't have the answer for this
thing so I'm gonna I'm gonna ask Jocko
what is just what does he think right as
you're asking them you're like oh I know
what he's gonna say right right so this
one he was like I was like ah I know
what this guy's gonna say right now sooo
stupid with your song something like
that so it's more like I get it stop
being weak okay but there's a little bit
more to that like what do you say like
what do you think or whatever you know
I'm like alright yeah we're gonna record
that and these chocolate tracks they
have it for anything not just skipping
workouts for procrastination getting up
early all this stuff so it's kind of
like even if your volumes not turned up
it's kind of like Jacko's actually
telling you like hottest not skip the
work though it's good
it's encouragement yeah yeah yeah I was
nice how come people are always like oh
you should make a thing of you yelling
at me to get out of bed yeah I you know
I really think that that would work but
it would only work like a few times
after a while it's kind of like oh you
know yeah cool according of chuckling
but if you're you know how like you're
talking like home you know so like it's
kind of like you're explained expressly
you know like it's enough a reminder of
that game get back on the path yeah yeah
really there you go but yeah good one
get down on iTunes
but basically anywhere where they sell
and beat yeah yeah it's available one
preview simply supports the also when
you're on Amazon you can get choco white
tea now the good thing about there's
some good things and bad things about
jakka white tea the bad things are is
you got to mix it up with hot water that
can take a little extra time the good
things is once you drink about 1/2 a cup
of white tea this is what we're finding
now when you drink about 1/2 a cup of
white tea you are then able to deadlift
8,000 pounds a lot of time wondering how
much you had to drink and the answer is
you can drink a half a cup and you're
there so you can get doc a white team
and it's also legal which a lot of
people are trying to get it outlawed
right now by you know the Athletic
Commission and the Olympics they don't
want people breaking records and
everything so yeah they're trying to
just ban it but get it while you can
right get it while you can before it
gets banned before it gets banned and
then you're just done also some books
the books that I read on the podcast for
sure
there's also book called a lot of the
books I read in the podcast are are for
adults clearly a lot of Mar very you
need a mature audience but kids also
need to know how to get on the path am i
right you got kids you got kids kids
need to know how to get on the path how
they gonna get on path well number one
they can get the book away the warrior
kid and they can get on the path with
that and now there's another book coming
out its way the warrior kid to sequel
the sequel cool could it be but jaws to
fail there's always that chance a tenth
if I would have listened to my publisher
yeah cuz the what do they want to do
they want you to churn out hey you've
got a little bit going here right get
another one let's ride the wave right
yeah and by the way let us help you
shape you know where we think we this
could go oh so you just want to take it
down that path no we're not going down
that path life's hard Mark's gonna face
some more struggles and he does luckily
he's got an uncle Jake comes and help
them out way the warrior kid marks
mission you can pre-order it right now
it comes out April 24th is the date that
it comes out you can get that also if
you're adult you want to get on the path
stay on the path be on the path move
down the path you can get a book called
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
which echoes apparently knows all about
field manuals my favorite kind of man
you have favorite kind of manuals this
is gonna help you stay on the path
that's what its gonna do not only what
you should think about in a section
called thoughts but also the actions you
should take if you want to proceed to
get stronger faster smarter and
all-round better and if you want the
audio version don't look for it on
audible because it's not there this is
an album also with tracks and it's
available in mp3 format from Amazon
music from Google Play from other mp3
platforms and actually let's talk a
little bit about I don't know a couple
books we wrote a little company we got
maybe a little event that we're doing
first and foremost if you want to dive
deeper and the leadership principles
that we've been talking about and
referencing get extreme ownership that's
we have people ask us like hey where did
you make mistakes in your career we
wrote a whole book about them that's
what extremely oceans about the mistakes
we learn on the battlefield
the things that happen to us what we
learn from them and then how that
principle applies the business in life
so go get that book on Amazon or
anywhere that you can buy books and if
you're like me and you're super busy and
you don't have a lot of time to read
then you can get the audible book now
the audio book it's on audible it's on
anywhere and and get get that version
and we read it by the way
we read it James Earl Jones wasn't
available so Batman was we we we had to
read it i didn't realize i was the texas
batman until people are listening to
this book yeah yeah turn that was born
on social media I hear good things about
the audio version though they're a tough
there's there's little surprises in the
audio version that it once again we
didn't listen to our publisher our
publisher was like well that's kind of
weird to put that well we well what
would you rather hear for a gun fire uh
you know me going bop bop bop
bop-bop-bop or would you rather hear
gunfire what would you rather hear for
an explosion Lafe going kaboom or would
you rather have explosion what would you
rather have for the call to prayer lathe
talking about the call to prayer coming
because it can be pretty eerie in those
situations would you rather actually
hear it so they're saying what would you
call that audio theater sure you make
you think you call that yeah how do you
okay and they did a great job of that
with the audio book so get that that's
certainly an option as well and if you
have a company or you want to work work
with us extra on front that's our that's
our company Isilon front knee and if
you're looking to to implement these
leadership programs in your team learn
from us learn learn those same
principles that we talked about then
that's what we do and that's not front
is we we come out and work with your
team we and and we come out and work
with your team and and get these
principles apply to your particular
challenges that you could lead and win
on your battlefield and that's just that
that what esle on front is is our
company it's Jocko it's me it's Dave
Burke its J Peter Nell guys that you
know from from this podcast and on a
whole team of folks is Jocko talked
about the tank where we talk about these
leadership problems we solve those
problems
and and we help you lead and win and
that's awesome we love that so if you're
interested in in working with us go to a
salon front comm and of course the
muster which we talked about this is the
ultimate Leadership Conference and and
ever we got four of these so far every
single one of them have sold them every
single one of us sold out so don't wait
if you were interested in coming we're
only doing two this year we're only
doing - we had a lot going on for us and
we said we're gonna do two
amazing musters that's what we're gonna
focus on we did three last year we're
only doing two this year and that's in
Washington DC May 17th and 18th and
that's in San Francisco October 17th and
18th and that's it if you want to if you
want to come and be a part of the
monster go to extreme ownership calm and
get registered and we'll see you there
and until the muster if you want to kind
of continue this conversation that we're
having right now you can find us
continually conversing on the interwebs
on Twitter on Instagram E and on that
face hahaha
life is that life babban echo is at echo
Charles and I am at chakra willing echo
Charles anything else no a
self-correcting machine that's what
happens when you start doing the extreme
ownership thing that's the added layer I
gathered from today legit I like it
thanks for a Gina clarify oh it's good
to see you thanks for having me not safe
any closing thoughts good to be on again
willing it for the next time
I suppose we'll do one more of when
we're up at the muster we'll talk more
maybe we'll talk more about probably
talk a little bit about extreme emotion
maybe we'll talk a little bit more about
the new book which will be done for the
most part by then awesome obviously
thanks for coming on thanks to everyone
out there especially those of you who
are out there in uniform who have
basically said I am willing to give
everything I have for freedom we're here
today because of you so thank you thank
you to the police and the law
enforcement and the firefighters and the
paramedics and the rest of the first
responders that do their job every day
every day to make sure that we are safe
here at home and everyone else out there
that's listening and sharing and
supporting this podcast thank you but
don't just listen and
don't just support and don't just share
but instead wake up every day with a
mission wake up every day with a goal to
be a little bit better than you were
yesterday and become the self-correcting
machine that's not going to bring you to
perfection but it's gonna bring you to a
place that's a little bit closer so get
out there and get after it and until
next time this is life and echo and
Jocko